I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hello.
Hi.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室女郎 6.0。你好。嗨。
I am really excited about today because we are going to be reading each other our summer travel journals.
I know.
I really hope it doesn't disappoint.
We wrote about our trips.
Yes.
So for spring break, I went to Japan and you went home to Texas and you did some college tours.
And we're kind of flipping it this time.
I went home to visit my family and you went to Wimbledon.
我对今天的内容感到非常兴奋，因为我们要互相朗读彼此的盛夏旅行日记。我知道。我真的很希望它不会让人失望。我们写下了各自的旅行经历。是的。所以春假期间，我去了日本，而你回了德克萨斯州，参观了一些大学。而这次我们有点反其道而行之。我回家看望家人，而你去了温布尔登。
Yes, in London.
And you have not told me a single Wimbledon story.
No, because you were like, let's journal about our travels.
So I purposely saved it.
I know.
And I have been dying to hear about this trip.
because I just know what a bucket list item it is for you.
And now you've been.
是的，在伦敦。而你连一个温布尔登的故事都没有告诉我。对，因为你说过，让我们把旅行写成日记。所以我故意留着没说。我知道。我一直渴望听到这次旅行的经历，因为我知道这列在你的愿望清单上有多重要。现在你终于去过了。
And Sam, you went to Germany.
I did.
I went to Munich and then took a six-hour train to Osnabrook.
Ooh.
And Matt went camping in the sticks with no cell service.
That's right.
I was out of pocket.
All right.
还有萨姆，你去了德国。没错。我去了慕尼黑，然后坐了六个小时的火车去了奥斯纳布吕克。哦。马特则去荒郊野岭露营了，而且没有手机信号。没错。我当时处于失联状态。好吧。
Well, we're going to hear about all these things today.
But we thought it might be fun to start this episode with an office question of the week.
So rather than a chit-chat, we're going to dive into a little office talk.
And this question comes from Soha P in Bellingham, Washington, who said,
Hi, office ladies, I want to know absolutely everything about table reads.
For example, when you read a script, did you more or less say the words, or did you really
go for it from an acting perspective?
You mentioned that table read drafts could be pretty long, so did the table reads take like
嗯，我们今天会听到所有这些事情。但我们觉得，以本周的办公室问题来开启这一集可能会很有趣。所以，与其闲聊，不如让我们直接切入一点办公室话题。这个问题来自华盛顿州贝灵汉的索哈·P，她说：“嗨，办公室女郎，我想知道关于台词围读（table reads）的绝对所有细节。例如，当你们阅读剧本时，你们是多多少少读出台词，还是从表演的角度真正全力以赴？你们曾提到过，围读初稿可能会相当长，那么围读会花了比如
over an hour to go through?
You also mentioned that you did table reads at lunch, so did you have to time your bites
strategically. Finally, I'd love to hear more about what the very last table read for the finale
was like. Love you and your podcast. Such a great, specific question. So many different, many
questions within one overall question. I was a real fan of this. Well, I realize we do our best to
explain things, but sometimes we might just use a lingo or assume that people know what that looks
like. And so I like that we're going to dive into the specifics of a table read. Yeah. So first of all,
we did a table read once a week on Tuesdays. Now, most days of the week, we got an hour break for
一个多小时才读完吗？你们还提到过你们在午餐时进行台词围读，那你们是不是得精打细算地安排每一口饭的时间？最后，我很想听听大结局的最后一次台词围读是什么样的。爱你们和你们的播客。”这是一个非常棒、非常具体的问题。一个总问题里面包含了许多不同的小问题。我真的很喜欢这个。嗯，我意识到我们已经尽力解释事情了，但有时我们可能只是使用行话，或者假设人们知道那是什么样子的。所以我很高兴我们要深入探讨台词围读的具体细节。是的。所以首先，我们每周二进行一次台词围读。现在，一周中的大多数日子，我们有一小时的午餐
lunch. But on Tuesdays, we got 30 minutes for lunch. And then we would head over to the writer's
trailer. They had this big trailer for a table read. So we got to eat first. We did not have to time our
bites. Bites. Yeah.
Thankfully, though, right?
Because, like, us eating and reading out loud would have been a mess,
especially if you've ever watched Rain Wilson eat,
which you have if you've seen the office.
And then also we would receive a hard copy of the table read draft of the script,
休息时间。但周二的时候，我们只有30分钟的午餐时间。然后我们会前往编剧的拖车。他们有一个很大的拖车用来进行台词围读。所以我们可以先吃饭。我们不需要计算每口饭的时间。每一口。是的。谢天谢地，对吧？因为，比如，如果我们一边吃一边大声朗读，那会是一团糟，尤其是如果你看过雷恩·威尔逊吃东西的话——如果你看过《办公室》，你肯定看过。然后我们还会收到一份台词围读版剧本的纸质拷贝，
usually Tuesday morning.
Like, you would already start filming and you'd go in your trailer and you'd be like,
ooh, the new script's there.
Yes.
Yeah.
And if we had time, we would flip through it.
Maybe we'd read it in the hair and makeup trailer,
maybe during breaks and filming.
通常是在周二早上。就像，你已经开始拍摄了，然后你走进你的拖车，你会想，哦，新剧本在那儿。是的。是的。如果我们有时间，我们会翻看一下。也许我们在美发化妆拖车里读，也许在拍摄间隙读。
But sometimes we wouldn't get a script
until we walked into the writer's trailer.
And so we were doing what is called a cold read.
Yeah, where you've never seen the words you're about to say.
What's interesting to me, though, ladies,
it's called a cold read,
but when we would get those scripts right as we walked in,
they'd be warm from the printer.
但有时直到我们走进编剧的拖车，我们才拿到剧本。所以我们进行的是所谓的“盲读”（cold read）。是的，你从来没见过你即将要说出的台词。不过，女士们，让我觉得有趣的是，这被称为盲读，但当我们一走进去拿到那些剧本时，它们还是从打印机里出来热乎的。
So it was actually kind of a warm read.
Yeah.
And then inside the writer's trailer,
there were these four long tables,
and they were set up in a rectangle shape.
with chairs all around.
Yeah, like the four tables were like rectangles that made then one giant rectangle.
Yes.
所以实际上它算是一种“温读”（warm read）。是的。然后，在编剧的拖车里，有四张长桌子，它们被摆放成矩形形状，
If that makes sense.
And we could take a seat wherever we wanted, but there was this one chair that was positioned
in the center of the top table and it was a really nice chair.
It had arms and we always left that one for Steve.
I never wanted to sit in that chair.
It felt too important.
I know.
And it's not like he insisted that was his chair or anything.
四周都放着椅子。是的，就像那四张桌子拼成了一个巨大的矩形。是的。如果能理解的话。我们可以坐在任何我们想坐的地方，但在最前面的那张桌子的正中央有一把椅子，那是一把非常好的椅子。它有扶手，我们总是把那把椅子留给史蒂夫。我从来不想坐那张椅子。它感觉太重要了。我知道。并不是说他坚持那是他的椅子什么的。
This was just something we kind of collectively did out of respect.
Yeah, I was usually on like one of the sides.
Like I would just file in.
And, you know, there was also rows of chairs at the far end of the trailer where network
execs would come and sit.
Yes.
Or the writers would sit.
Oh, yeah.
这只是我们出于尊重而共同做出的举动。是的，我通常坐在旁边之类的。我就跟着排队入座。而且，你知道，拖车的尽头也有一排排椅子，电视网的高管们会来坐在那里。是的。或者编剧们会坐那里。哦，是的。
And take notes.
I do want to say that when Kathy Bates came to guest stars, Steve gave her the nice chair.
Yeah.
And then after Steve left, I remember none of us would sit in the chair.
chair for like weeks. You know, it was interesting because no one talked about it. I know. That's what I,
when I was thinking about table reads. I was like, remember the chair? The chair. We just were like,
no, we're not sitting in that. That was Steve's. You mentioned Kathy Bates being there. Would most
major guest stars go to table reads? Yes, major guest stars who had recurring roles, even a weekly guest star who
并做记录。我想说的是，当凯西·贝茨来客串时，史蒂夫把那把好椅子让给了她。是的。然后在史蒂夫离开后，我记得我们谁都不肯去坐那把椅子，好几个星期都没有人坐。你知道，这很有趣，因为没有人谈论它。我知道。这就是我，当我想起台词围读时。我就想，还记得那把椅子吗？那把椅子。我们只是觉得，不，我们不坐那个。那是史蒂夫的。你提到凯西·贝茨在那里，大多数重要的客星都会去参加台词围读吗？是的，有常驻角色的重要客星，甚至是被及时选中的每周客星
was cast in time. Okay. So they would come and do the table reads. Oh, interesting. Okay. Yeah.
But like James Spader came to the table reads.
Exactly.
It really came down to also if it had been cast by the Tuesday and that person had been contacted.
Oh, okay.
You know, so sometimes those roles weren't cast until later in the week.
So our writers would fill in and read the roles that were all the extra parts.
Oh, interesting.
都会去。好吧。所以他们会来参加台词围读。哦，很有趣。好吧。是的。不过，比如詹姆斯·斯派德也来参加台词围读。没错。这其实也取决于周二之前角色是否已经定好，以及是否已经联系了那个人。哦，好吧。你知道，所以有时这些角色直到一周晚些时候才定下来。因此我们的编剧会顶上，阅读所有多余角色的台词。哦，很有趣。
Okay.
Let's see.
What were the other things that Soho wanted to hear about?
Oh, they usually took about 45 minutes.
Mm-hmm.
And in general, we really all went for it.
we read in character how we might perform the scene.
But of course, everyone knew we were making our choices kind of on the spot.
好吧。让我想想。索哈还想听些什么来着？哦，它们通常大约需要45分钟。嗯哼。总的来说，我们确实都全力以赴。我们以角色的身份来朗读，就像我们要表演那个场景一样。但当然，每个人都知道我们在现场做出自己的选择。
And, you know, once it was over, we, the actors had to get back to set.
So we had to get ready for our scenes that were up after lunch.
So we pretty much filed out.
Like, we didn't hang out and linger.
Yes.
No, the writers and Greg and the director, they would stay.
They would give notes on what they thought worked and what didn't.
They would make a list of assignments for rewrites.
而且，你知道，一旦结束，我们演员就得回到片场。所以我们得为午餐后要拍的戏做准备。所以我们差不多就像排队离开一样。我们没有闲逛逗留。是的。不，编剧、格雷格和导演，他们会留下来。他们会就他们认为行得通和行不通的地方提出意见。他们会列出一份重写任务清单，
and the actors did not stay for notes.
And there were no performance notes.
No one would come and talk to us about our performance.
This is just all about the script.
And when I was a producer in season nine,
I got to stay for the notes sessions.
And they were fascinating.
Fascinating.
而演员们则不会留下来听意见。而且也没有表演方面的意见。没有人会来找我们谈论我们的表演。这完全是关于剧本的。当我在第九季担任制片人时，我得以留下来参加意见反馈环节。它们太迷人了。迷人。
Sometimes it would just be as small as like,
hey, I want you to write alt jokes for that line.
And then sometimes it would be whole storyline.
that they would say, I think we need to rethink this.
We need to reinvent this.
It needs more conflict or it needs more something fascinating.
And as far as the final table read, that was really a huge deal.
We weren't in our writer's trailer because we were on location.
有时只是很小的事情，比如，嘿，我希望你为那句台词写一些备用笑话。有时则会涉及到整个故事情节，他们会说，我觉得我们需要重新考虑这个。我们需要重塑这个。它需要更多的冲突，或者需要更多迷人的东西。至于最后一次台词围读，那真的是一件大事。我们不在我们的编剧拖车里，因为我们在外景地。
So we were in this big room.
There were rows and rows and rows of chairs for anyone that had ever worked on the show in any way was there and was watching.
They had a camera set up to film it.
Yeah, we did not usually film.
our table reads. And there was, you know, Chris Hasten took photos, but several people took pictures,
like just even from our crew, people were just documenting the moment. And the table was set up in
this huge, like, you shape. And we had microphones, which we normally didn't have. Yeah. And we would
have the occasional NBC executive stopped by our weekly table reads, but we were far from the main lot.
所以我们在一个大房间里。里面摆满了椅子，一排又一排，任何曾经以某种方式为这部剧工作过的人都在那里观看。他们架设了摄像机进行拍摄。是的，我们通常不拍摄我们的台词围读。而且，你知道，克里斯·哈斯滕拍了照片，但好几个人都拍了照片，甚至连我们的剧组人员也在记录这一刻。桌子摆成了一个巨大的U形。我们有麦克风，这通常是没有的。是的。我们会偶尔有NBC高管顺道来参加我们每周的台词围读，但我们离主摄影棚很远，
And they did not make that track.
But for the final table read, it was like every executive who worked at NBC was at that table
read.
Exactly.
It was a huge deal.
Huge deal.
And our table reads for so many years, like Jenna said, I mean, the first year, we sat in a circle on the stage, like the Dundermifflin office.
Yeah, we just pulled our roly chairs up around the Dwight gym desk clump.
他们不会特意跑那一趟。但对于最后的台词围读，感觉就像在NBC工作的每个高管都出席了那次台词围读。没错。这真是件大事。超级大事。多年来我们的台词围读，就像珍娜说的，我的意思是，第一年，我们在舞台上围成一圈坐着，就像邓德米夫林的办公室一样。是的，我们把带轮子的椅子拉到德怀特健身房办公桌群周围。
Yeah.
We would just sit there.
In fact, when my parents visited in the early seasons of the office, we did the table.
we did the table read.
My parents sat in a rolly chair by like Creed's desk and listened to us read the script.
So it was kind of interesting to see the progression.
And then as the years went on, then we had the trailer and then we had network execs
that would come.
是的，我们就坐在那里。事实上，当我的父母在《办公室》早期几季来探班时，我们做过台词围读。我们做了台词围读。我父母坐在克里德的办公桌旁边的转椅上，听我们读剧本。所以看着这个发展过程挺有趣的。然后随着时间的推移，我们有了拖车，然后有电视网高管会来。
And then, yeah, ended it with this huge crowd.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, that was fun.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for that question.
I actually just loved revisiting all of that in my brain.
It was fun to remember.
然后，是的，以这样庞大的人群结束。是的。好了，那很有趣。是的。非常感谢你的这个问题。我其实很喜欢在脑海中重新温习这一切。回忆起来很有趣。
Mm-hmm. All right. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, I'm going to share about Lake of the Ozarks.
Where I want to go with you. I want to go with you. I need to go. And I can't wait to hear about your trip.
What is Toyota affordability? It all starts with buying smart. And your Toyota dealer has great deals available to qualified customers on reliable cars and SUVs, including the redesigned Rav4, Spacious Grand Highlander, Sporty Camrys and Corollas. It means driving for less with the
hybrid and plug-in hybrid options available throughout the lineup, extending your overall
driving range and delivering great MPGs, saving you money at the pump. And it means trading for
more. Toyota is known for building long-lasting vehicles and has the best resale value brand
according to Kelly Blue Book, your Toyota can be worth thousands more than average when it's
time to trade in. That's Toyota affordability. Buy smart, drive for less, and trade for more.
嗯哼。好了，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？等我们回来，我要分享关于奥沙克湖的故事。我想和你一起去的地方。我想和你一起去。我得去。我等不及要听你的旅行了。什么是丰田的经济实惠？一切都从明智购买开始。您的丰田经销商为合格客户提供优质汽车和SUV的超值优惠，包括重新设计的Rav4、宽敞的大汉兰达、动气的凯美瑞和卡罗拉。这意味着通过整个系列提供的混合动力和插电式混合动力选项，以更少的油耗驾驶，延长您的整体行驶里程，并提供出色的每加仑英里数（MPG），在加油时为您省钱。这意味着以旧换新获得更高价值。丰田以制造经久耐用的汽车而闻名，根据凯利蓝皮书（Kelly Blue Book），它拥有最佳保值率品牌，当您准备以旧换新时，您的丰田汽车可以比平均水平多值数千美元。这就是丰田的经济实惠。明智购买，省油驾驶，换购更多。
Shop Toyota.com or your local dealer for deals and details.
Vehicle's projected resale value is specific to the 2026 model year.
For more information, visit Kelly Blue Books, KB.com.
Toyota brand average resale value is 53% versus the average vehicle at 45%.
Toyota, let's go places.
What the heck is going on with all these promotional popcorn buckets?
The giant shorts that all of Gen Z is wearing now and whatever the heck, Hirox is?
I'm comedian and certified hater, Matt Bellisai,
访问Shop Toyota.com或您当地的经销商了解优惠和详情。汽车的预计保值率特定于2026车型年。欲了解更多信息，请访问Kelly Blue Books KB.com。丰田品牌的平均保值率为53%，而普通汽车为45%。丰田，让我们出发。所有这些促销爆米花桶到底是怎么回事？Z世代现在穿的巨型短裤，以及那个什么希罗克斯（Hirox）到底是什么鬼？我是喜剧演员兼认证差评师马特·贝利萨伊，
and these are the types of questions I'm demanding answers to on my podcast,
what the heck with Matt Belisai.
Listen or watch every Thursday as I rant about all the internet trends,
pop culture stories, and personal mayhem that makes me scream,
what the heck?
Follow What the Heck with Matt Belisai wherever you get your podcasts.
All right, we are back from break and are you ready to go to the lake of the Ozarks with Jenna Fisher?
All right, well, here we go.
这些就是我在我的播客《马特·贝利萨伊的搞什么鬼》（What the Heck with Matt Belisai）中要求得到答案的问题类型。每周四收听或收看我痛斥所有让我忍不住尖叫“搞什么鬼”的网络趋势、流行文化故事和个人混乱。在您获取播客的任何地方关注《马特·贝利萨伊的搞什么鬼》。好了，我们休息归来，你准备好和珍娜·菲舍尔一起去奥沙克湖了吗？好的，我们开始吧。
I journaled each morning, just to give you some context.
I was going to ask you about that because I would jot things down as my day went and my notes at,
and then I would either have to journal like at night or in the morning the next day.
Yes, because it was, you know, wall-to-wall activities all day, family, all that.
So here we go.
Lake of the Ozarks Summer Travel Journal, first morning at the lake.
You're sitting so properly.
I wish you guys could see her.
我每天早上都会写日记，只是为了给你提供一些背景。我正想问你这个，因为我会在白天随手记下一些事情，然后我得在晚上或者第二天早上写日记。是的，因为你知道，整天都是连轴转的活动，家人，诸如此类。所以，我们开始吧。奥沙克湖夏日旅行日记，在湖边的第一个早晨。你坐得真端正。我真希望你们能看到她。
She's like, with her hands clasped in front of her.
I don't know why.
I feel like I'm giving a speech.
Okay.
I'm sitting out under a big covered patio.
It has two ceiling fans, which is amazing because we were having a heat wave.
It's 9.40 a.m. and it's already 90 degrees outside.
We are here during the week before 4th of July.
她就像那样，双手交叠在身前。我不知道为什么。我觉得我在做演讲。好吧。我坐在一个大的带顶遮阳露台下。它有两个吊扇，这太棒了，因为我们当时正赶上热浪。现在是上午9点40分，外面已经有90华氏度了。我们在独立日前一周来到这里。
I hope that means the lake will be less busy and we can go for a long boat ride
without getting thrown around too much.
My folks have had a place at Lake of the Ozark since I was eight years old.
Or maybe my sister was eight and I was 13.
I'll have to ask my mom.
But we came here even before that every summer from as far back as I can recall.
I think it's safe to say I've been coming here for over 45 years.
Older than some of y'all listening.
我希望这意味着湖里不会那么拥挤，我们可以进行一次漫长的乘船游览，而不会被颠簸得太厉害。自我八岁起，我父母在奥沙克湖就有一个地方。或者也许我妹妹八岁，我十三岁？我得问问我妈妈。但从我记事起，每年夏天甚至在此之前，我们都会来这里。我想可以肯定地说，我来这里已经超过45岁了。比你们听众中的一些人还要老。
Yes.
Thank you for making that clear.
My parents' place started as a two-bedroom cabin they had built on a spot that I remember first visiting by boat.
It is in a quiet side cove and there is a soft rocky beach and I remember pulling our little red speedboat up onto that shore,
tying it to a tree with a long yellow plasticy rope, having a picnic lunch and watching my parents talk about putting a house there.
The soft rocky beach was discussed many times as a big plus.
It meant we could slowly wait into the water from shore while we waited for a dock to be built.
Had they already bought the land?
是的。谢谢你把这一点说清楚。我父母的地方最初是他们在一个地方建造的两居室小屋，我记得第一次坐船去参观时就是那个地方。它在一个安静的小海湾里，有一片柔软的岩石海滩，我记得把我们的红色小快艇拉到那个岸上，用一根长长的黄色塑料绳把它系在树上，吃一顿野餐，看着我父母讨论在那里建一所房子。那片柔软的岩石海滩被多次讨论为一个巨大的优势。这意味着在等待码头建造的同时，我们可以慢慢涉水从岸边走到水中。他们当时已经买下这块地了吗？
I'm not sure.
Again, maybe I should ask about these details, but more than anything, I think it's cool that they made this dream come true for themselves.
I remember driving down over the next year watching as the house was built.
All of the anticipatory excitement.
Two bedrooms, one bath, a utility room, which also houses the washer dryer and all of my dad's tools,
a kitchen living room and a great big deck facing the lake.
I remember their decision to put their bedroom in the front of the house with a lake view and deck access,
and our bedroom in the back of the house.
我不确定。再说一次，也许我应该问问这些细节，但最重要的是，我觉得他们让这个梦想成真是一件很酷的事。我记得第二年开车南下，看着房子一点点建起来。所有的期待和兴奋。两间卧室，一间浴室，一间杂物间，里面还放着洗衣机烘干机和爸爸所有的工具，一个厨房客厅和一个面向湖泊的超大露台。我记得他们决定把卧室放在房子前面，带湖景和露台出入口，而把我们的卧室放在房子后面。
Theirs was small, just big enough for a queen bed in two nightstands.
Ours was much bigger with bunk beds and a couch and a large walk-in closet,
which served as a place to put life vests,
overflow food items, skis, and even a drying rack for swimsuits.
That's a big closet.
It was really big.
You could almost fit a twin bed in there.
It was almost like another room.
他们的房间很小，刚刚好放下一张大床和两个床头柜。我们的房间大得多，有双层床、一张沙发和一个大型步入式衣帽间，这个衣帽间兼作存放救生衣、多余食品、滑雪板甚至泳衣晾衣架的地方。那真是一个大衣帽间。真的很大。你几乎可以在里面塞下一张单人床。它几乎就像另一个房间。
When we were teenagers, we could put blankets on the ground
and hide in the closet for privacy.
incidentally, the bunk beds had no railing on the upper bunk.
It's not like how they are today.
And since I was older, I got the top bunk even though my daredevil sister really wanted it.
I fell out of that bed in the middle of the night at least once a year.
I do feel like our generation was just like, well, yeah, not a railing insight.
Just fair it out.
当我们是青少年时，我们可以在地上铺上毯子，躲在衣帽间里求得隐私。顺便说一句，双层床的上铺没有栏杆。跟现在的可不一样。由于我是姐姐，我睡了上铺，尽管我那喜欢冒险的妹妹非常想要它。我每年至少有一次在半夜从那张床上掉下来。我觉得我们这一代人就是那种，“嗯，对啊，连个栏杆的影子都没有。自己想办法吧。”
No seat belts.
Yeah, you'll be fine.
You can lay on the floorboard while we drive.
The top bunk now belongs to my niece, and we laughed about the fact that she, too, has fallen out in the middle of the night.
My dad even attempted to add a safety railing, but I guess it didn't work.
So the bed is still, the bunk bed is still there from my childhood.
Yes, same bunk bed.
With no railing.
没有安全带。对，我们在开车时你可以躺在地板上。上铺现在属于我的侄女，我们笑着谈论她也曾在半夜掉下来过。我爸爸甚至试图加装一个安全栏杆，但我想没起作用。所以这张床依然，双层床依然是我童年时的那个。是的，还是那张双层床。没有栏杆。
Well, my sister was like, if my children are going to sleep in this bunk bed, dad, it needs some sort of railing.
But then my niece and I were talking, and she was like, oh, yeah, I fall out of that.
like we're seeing. She's went right through the railing. Yeah, I guess so. And I was like, oh, no,
C, C.C. We bonded. Moving on. I'm almost done with morning one. A few years ago, my parents expanded
the house, adding on a second story and two additional bedrooms. It's big enough now that my sister
and her kids can come down and stay, but not quite big enough to also house me and Lee and our
kids, so we usually get an Airbnb somewhere nearby. Our place this year is great. I slept so
well in the bedroom. That was in all caps so well. Now, this is the one thing you shared with me
嗯，我妹妹说，“如果我的孩子要睡在这个双层床里，爸爸，它需要某种栏杆。”但后来我和侄女聊天时，她说，“哦，对啊，我从那儿掉下来过。”就像我们看到的那样。她直接穿过了栏杆。是的，我想是的。然后我说，“哦，不，C.C.。”我们因此建立了感情。继续。我快写完第一个早晨了。几年前，我父母扩建了房子，加盖了第二层和两间额外的卧室。现在它足够大了，我妹妹和她的孩子可以下来住，但还不足以同时容纳我和李以及我们的孩子，所以我们通常会在附近租一间爱彼迎（Airbnb）。我们今年的这个地方很棒。我在卧室里睡得太好了。那是全大写的“睡得太好了”。现在，这是你关于这次旅行向我分享的唯一一件事，
about this trip because we tried to keep secrets so that we could share them today. But you were like,
oh my God, lady, I was so good. To know Jenna is to know how important sleep is. Yeah. It's true.
I wrote, great mattress. But the best thing is the big covered deck with the fans facing the lake.
Oh, and there's a mama cat and two little kittens living under the house next door to us.
It is very hard not to rescue these kittens.
They seem to be around the same age we usually get them to foster, right on the brink of being able to still be domesticated.
The mom is young.
I think the best we can do is put out some wet food while we're here to help her produce milk.
因为我们试图保守秘密以便今天分享。但你说，“哦，天哪，女士，我太棒了。”了解珍娜就知道睡眠有多重要。是的。真的。我写道，床垫很棒。但最棒的是那个朝向湖泊、带有风扇的大型带顶露台。哦，我们隔壁的房子底下住着一只猫妈妈和两只小猫。要忍住不去救助这些小猫真的很难。它们的年龄似乎和我们通常接来寄养的差不多，正处于即将能够被驯化的边缘。猫妈妈很年轻。我想我们能做的最好的事情就是在我们呆在这里的时候放一些湿粮来帮她分泌乳汁。
Aw.
All right.
Are you ready for morning, too?
Yeah.
Well, yesterday was your quintessential lake day.
swimming, boat ride, trip to the grocery store for some item we forgot to bring with us,
more swimming, my dad's barbecue, family game World Cup. We played the game celebrity. There were nine of
噢。好了。你们准备好迎接第二个早晨了吗？好了。嗯，昨天是典型的湖畔一天。游泳、乘船游览、去杂货店买我们忘记带的东西、更多的游泳、我爸爸的烧烤、家庭游戏世界杯。我们玩了名人猜猜乐游戏。当时有九个人
us playing, and it was pretty cool to play with three generations. We had names like Richard Chamberlain.
That stumped the kids. The kids did not know. To Millie Bobby Brown, my parents did not know.
But what I found really interesting are the celebrities that ended up in the bowl multiple times.
I'm not sure what it says about their fame, but Will Farrell was in the bowl four times.
Oh.
Madonna and Sabrina Carpenter were both in there three times.
There were also two Michael Jackson's and two Barack Obama's.
We divided up girls against the boys and the girls won, handily.
在玩，三代人一起玩感觉挺酷的。我们有像理查德·张伯伦这样的名字。这把孩子们难住了。孩子们不知道。还有米莉·鲍比·布朗，我父母不知道。但我发现真正有趣的是那些多次出现在碗里的名人。我不知道这说明了他们的什么名气，但威尔·法瑞尔在碗里出现了四次。哦。麦当娜和萨布丽娜·卡彭特都出现了三次。还有两个迈克尔·杰克逊和两个巴拉克·奥巴马。我们将女生和男生分组对抗，女生赢了，赢得轻而易举。
Oh, handily.
This morning we all slept into 10 a.m., glorious.
To our body clocks, that is 8 a.m. L.A. time, but still.
Have I said the bed in my Airbnb is super comfy with a ceiling fan, which is kind of the best thing ever if you have hot flashes?
It's making me want to put a ceiling fan in at home.
I woke up to a text from my sister that she and my mom were going to go to the local thrift store called Hope House.
My mom had some donations to drop off, and she also just loves looking around.
My sister said my dad was going to Walmart to grab something not sure what.
哦，轻而易举。今天早上我们都睡到上午10点，太美妙了。按照我们的生物钟，那是洛杉矶时间早上8点，不过依然很晚。我说过我爱彼迎的房间里的床超级舒服，还有吊扇吗？如果你有潮热的话，这简直是世上最棒的事。这让我想在家里也装一个吊扇。我醒来时看到我妹妹发来的短信，说她和我妈妈要去当地一家名为“希望之家”（Hope House）的旧货店。我妈妈有一些捐赠物要送去，而且她也很喜欢随便逛逛。我妹妹说我爸爸要去沃尔玛买点东西，不确定是什么。
And yet, as of noon, my sister and my mom have still not gone.
to Hope House, which is pretty typical.
First of all, they realized that the donations they wanted to drop off were in my dad's car,
so they had to wait for him to get back from Walmart.
There's a little bit of shade.
A scoge of shade.
Every tenth word is a dagger.
Typical.
然而，直到中午，我妹妹和我妈妈仍然没有去成希望之家，这也是相当典型的情况。首先，他们意识到他们想捐赠的东西在我爸爸的车里，所以他们不得不等他从沃尔玛回来。这里有点讽刺。一点点讽刺。每十个词里就有一把尖刀。典型。
I mean, it is though.
I guess I'm super like bragging and shady in my turtle with my family.
You know what?
the boys were all thinking they were going to crush us in celebrity, and they did not win,
and they very much did not win.
Okay, okay.
And now did your mom and sister ever make it?
I'll let you know.
我是说，确实如此。我想我在日记里对我的家人确实挺爱显摆又带刺的。你知道吗？男生们都以为他们能在名人猜猜乐里把我们碾压，结果他们没赢，而且输得很惨。好吧，好吧。那你妈妈和妹妹最后到底去了吗？我会让你们知道的。
I will let you know.
You have to wait for it.
But this is the thing.
They'll tell us, oh, the plan for the day is we're going to Hope Post at 10 a.m.
And then at noon, no one has left.
This is like very typical of my family.
All right.
So anyway, the problem was the stuff was in my dad's car.
我会让你们知道的。你们得等一下。但事情就是这样。他们会告诉我们，“哦，今天的计划是我们上午10点去希望之家。”然后到了中午，谁也没走。这非常符合我们家的一贯作风。所以无论如何，问题在于东西在我爸爸的车里。
They had to wait for him to get back from all.
They dropped the kids at our place at 1215, so the cousins are reunited and watching the World
Cup.
And just now, my sister texts me that they made it to Hope House.
It's 1 p.m.
It's close.
They're coming back home.
My sister said, Mom, the sign clearly says they are open Monday, Wednesday, and Friday.
他们不得不等他从沃尔玛回来。他们在12点15分把孩子送到我们这儿，所以表兄弟姐妹们团聚了，正在看世界杯。就在刚才，我妹妹给我发短信说他们终于到了希望之家。现在是下午1点。真悬。他们正在回家的路上。我妹妹说：“妈，牌子上明明写着他们周一、周三和周五营业。”
This was a Tuesday.
But my mom's response was, yeah, that's what the sign says.
But sometimes they're open on Tuesdays.
They drove all the way there.
I spent the morning reading a play by Gina Gianfrido.
I hope I'm saying her name right.
When we were in New York, we saw the revival of her play Becky Shaw, which I absolutely loved.
So now I'm reading her other plays because I love living in her dialogue.
今天是星期二。但我妈妈的回答是，“对，牌子上是这么写的。但有时他们周二也开门。”他们大老远开车去了那里。我整个上午都在读吉娜·吉安弗里多的一部剧本。希望我没念错她的名字。我们在纽约时，看过她的话剧《贝基·肖》（Becky Shaw）的复排版，我非常喜欢。所以我现在在读她的其他剧本，因为我喜欢沉浸在她的对话中。
Oh, I just finished the book yesteryear, which was a trip and a great summer page Turner.
It's kind of the book of the moment.
It's about a tradwife influencer who suddenly wakes up living an actual pioneer life like in the 1800s.
I read all fours by Miranda July earlier this year, and I feel like reading them both in the same year was very interesting.
In both instances, the protagonists are women who feel suffocated by what they perceive to be the confines of living a married life with children.
Very, very different protagonists, but similar theme.
They would make an interesting addition to a women's studies course.
Jenna, again, I'm on the same book train as you.
哦，我刚刚读完了书《昔日》（Yesteryear），这是一次奇妙的旅行，也是一本极佳的夏日翻书页。这可以说是当下最热门的书。它讲述了一个传统妻子网红突然醒来，发现自己过着18世纪那种真正的开拓者生活的故事。我今年早些时候读了米兰达·朱莉的《所有四重奏》（All Fours），我觉得在同一年读这两本书非常有趣。在这两个例子中，主角都是那些感到被自己所认为的有夫之妇生活所束缚的女性。非常、非常不同的主角，但主题相似。它们将为妇女研究课程增添有趣的内容。珍娜，再说一次，我和你看的是同一本书。
You are?
Yeah, you and I are three for three on marriage at sea strangers and yesteryear.
Matt, what did you think of yesteryear?
I loved it. I thought it was so interesting and funny.
And I don't know, just kind of write on kind of a different perspective than I would normally have.
I agree. I really, really liked it. It was quite a page turner. I think I tore through that in about four days.
Yeah, totally. Let's discuss. We can discuss more. All right. I go on to say,
but the book I finished recently that has become perhaps my all-time favorite book ever is Station 11.
是吗？对，你和我关于婚姻、陌生人和《昔日》是三战三胜。马特，你觉得《昔日》怎么样？我很喜欢。我觉得它非常有趣、好笑。而且不知道，就是那种直击心灵的感觉，有一种与我平时不同的视角。我同意。我真的非常喜欢它。它确实是一本让人爱不释卷的书。我想我大概用了四天时间就把它通读完了。对，完全是这样。我们讨论一下。我们可以讨论更多。好吧。我接着写道，但我最近读完的、或许已经成为我历来最喜欢的书是《站十 一》（Station 11）。
In the same way that Demon Copperhead created a fundamental shift in my awareness, Station 11 has too, but on an even deeper level.
It is the story of a flu that wipes out 99% of humanity. With only 1% of people left, all industry has stopped, all electricity, food production, transportation.
The story centers around a few characters and their experiences in these new times.
One of the main characters is a member of a troop of musicians and actors who go from settlement to settlement, to
performing Shakespeare and playing music. Their commitment to creating art in a world of survival
is intensely beautiful. They quote a line from Star Trek as their motto, quote, because survival
is insufficient, which is now maybe my favorite quote ever. It was a spiritual experience for me.
It had me pondering what it means to be human, the ways in which we are all interconnected during
就像《恶魔铜头蛇》（Demon Copperhead）在我的意识中产生了根本性的转变一样，《站十一》也是如此，但达到了更深的层面。这是一个关于流感消灭了99%人类的故事。只剩下1%的人口，所有的工业都停止了，所有的电力、食品生产、交通运输都停滞了。故事围绕着几个角色以及他们在这些新时期的经历展开。其中一个主要角色是一支由音乐家和演员组成的剧团的成员，他们从一个定居点走到另一个定居点，表演莎士比亚戏剧和演奏音乐。他们在充满生存威胁的世界里对创造艺术的执着是如此 intensa 美丽。他们引用《星际迷航》中的一句台词作为座右铭，引用：“因为仅凭生存是不够的”，这现在也许是我最喜欢的名言。这对我和来说是一次精神体验。它让我思考作为人类意味着什么，以及在我们在地球上流逝的时光中，我们所有人相互交织的方式。其中有一段关于雪景球的文字，
our passage of time on Earth. There is one paragraph about a snow-gloor.
that is now my favorite piece of writing.
I will never forget it.
I've gone back to it a few times since finishing the book.
When I read it over again, I feel a deep ache in my stomach
because what it evokes is so beautiful, it's hard to hold in my body.
I will never see a snow globe the same way again.
My goodness, I need to read that.
现在是我最喜欢的文学片段。我永远不会忘记它。自从读完这本书后，我又回去读了好几次。当我重新阅读它时，我的胃感到一阵深深的隐痛，因为唤起的情感是如此美丽，以至于很难在身体里承受。我再也不会用同样的眼光看待雪景球了。天哪，我得去读读那本书。
It's absolutely wonderful.
All right.
Moving on.
I wrote Moving on.
Moving on, I have a cat update.
We fed the mama three meals of wet food yesterday and also left out dry food overnight.
It was all gone in the morning.
She ate well yesterday, but no sign of her babies.
绝对精彩。好的。继续。我写了“继续”。继续，我有一个关于猫的最新消息。我们昨天给猫妈妈喂了三顿湿粮，还把干粮留在外面过夜。早上全吃光了。她昨天吃得很好，但没有她宝宝的踪迹。
Yesterday afternoon, I saw two Lake Otters also living under the house next door.
These people have a small petting zoo living under their deck.
I also saw a bunch of geese down by their dock this morning.
Oh, and my folks have a pair of ducks that swim with us and we can feed them out of our hands.
We are also seeing a ton of deer.
Lots of animals at the lake.
I love it.
All right.
昨天下午，我看到两只水獭也住在我们隔壁的房子下面。这些人简直在他们的露台下开了一个小型动物园。今天早上我还看到他们码头边有一群鹅。哦，我父母有一对鸭子跟我们一起游泳，我们可以用手喂它们。我们还看到了大量的鹿。湖里有好多动物。我太喜欢了。好的。
Next day.
Lake Day 3.
Good morning.
Somebody slept well.
Have I mentioned how much I liked it?
When we got back to the house last night, the mama cat ran over to the edge of our porch expectantly.
We put out some wet food and her two kittens also came up to eat.
This is when we got our first.
第二天。湖畔第三天。早上好。有人睡得很好。我提过我有多喜欢它吗？昨晚我们回到房子时，猫妈妈满怀期待地跑向我们门廊的边缘。我们放了一些湿粮，她的两只小猫也上来吃了。这时我们第一次
really good look at them. The mama is a gray tabby. She has a gray tabby look-alike kitten,
except that her baby has white paws, and then there is a super shy, smaller, all-black kitten.
I fed them three plates of wet food. They could not get enough. My daughter's angling for us
to take them back to St. Louis. She looked up the rules for flying them home. I told her that pets must
be up to date for their shots in order to fly, but she said she read online that, quote,
a lot of time Southwest doesn't even check.
Oh, no.
I said, quote,
真正看清了它们。猫妈妈是一只灰色虎斑猫。她有一只长相酷似灰色虎斑的小猫，除了她的宝宝有白色的爪子之外，然后还有一只超级害羞、更小的纯黑色小猫。我喂了它们三盘湿粮。它们怎么也吃不够。我女儿正盘算着把它们带回圣路易斯。她查了带它们坐飞机回家的规则。我告诉她宠物必须打完最新疫苗才能登机，但她说她在网上看到，“很多时候西南航空甚至都不会检查。”哦，不。我说，“
I'm not going to try and take three feral cats on an airplane,
but I'm feeling the same urge to rescue them as she is.
When you have a skill, which for us is cat rescue,
it's hard not to put that skill into action.
I also woke up realizing that this is our last full day here,
which means my last full day with my folks.
My dad is getting older.
He turns 80 this year.
我才不会试图带三只野猫上飞机，”但我跟她一样有着强烈的救助它们的冲动。当你拥有一项技能，对我们来说就是救助猫咪时，很难不去将这项技能付诸行动。我还醒来意识到这是我们在这里的最后一个完整的一天，这意味着我与父母共度的最后一个完整的一天。我爸爸老了。他今年80岁了。
And I'm always acutely aware that I'm on borrowed time
with them. I want to ask them more questions, but I'm not sure what those questions are.
Mostly, I just want to drink them in, particularly my dad here at the lake. He's always puttering around,
doing little chores, even at his age. Making barbecue ribs for dinner last night was a whole day affair.
It's multiple steps. I'm noticing him in every detail here, like all the do-it-yourself fixes
to little problems, like how he has a special spot to tie up the swim noodle.
on the dock or the sunshade he puts on hooks outside their bedroom window for when the sun is setting.
I'm trying to drink it all in. Yesterday was another typical lake day, tubing, boat rides, swimming,
我总是敏锐地意识到我和他们在一起的时间是借来的。我想问他们更多问题，但我不太确定那些问题是什么。主要是，我只是想细细品味他们，尤其是我的爸爸，在这里，在湖边。他总是在周围忙碌，做一些小杂务，甚至在他这个年纪也是如此。昨晚做烧烤排骨是一整天的工程。有多个步骤。我注意到这里的每一个细节，比如他所有针对小问题的DIY修复，比如他在码头上有一个专门用来系游泳浮条的地方，或者他在他们卧室窗外安放的遮阳篷，以便太阳落山时使用。我正试图把这一切都细细品味。昨天是又一个典型的湖畔一天，玩滑水圈、乘船游览、游泳，
my dad's delicious barbecue ribs for dinner, my mom's homemade coleslaw, or as she says,
cold slaw. Another game of celebrity. This time the boys won. We said we need to do a tiebreaker
tonight. By the way, I'm sorry to George Clooney, but none of the kids knew who he was.
Last night, we also did fireworks.
They are illegal in Los Angeles,
and it's super fun for the kids to do them each year
with their cousins of the lake.
On our drive down, we passed by so many fireworks stands
我爸爸美味的烧烤排骨作为晚餐，我妈妈自制的凉拌卷心菜，或者正如她所说的那样，“冷凉菜”（cold slaw）。又一局名人猜猜乐。这次男生赢了。我们说今晚需要进行一场决胜局。顺便说一下，对不起乔治·克鲁尼，但孩子们没有一个知道他是谁。昨晚，我们还放了烟花。这在洛杉矶是非法的，孩子们每年和表兄弟姐妹们在湖边一起放烟花觉得超级有趣。在我们开车南下的路上，我们路过了好多路边的烟花摊。
on the side of the road.
It's such a core memory of my childhood
around the 4th of July,
the roadside fireworks stand.
We got ours from a little place
in front of a gas station near my folks lake house.
We got the usual chicken, tank, fountains.
Then we went outside the box
这是我童年关于独立日的核心记忆之一，路边的烟花摊。我们从我父母湖屋附近一个加油站前的小地方买的。我们买常规的小鸡、坦克、喷泉烟花。然后我们不走寻常路，
and got something called big blue balls,
and one that was shaped like a slurpy.
And then we asked the guy at the stand,
what would make a good finale?
And he pointed us to this giant pack of rockets
for like $200.
Did you get them?
No.
买了一种叫作“大蓝色球”的东西，还有一个形状像思乐冰的。然后我们问摊位上的小伙子，什么能作为压轴好戏？他给我们指了这大包火箭烟花，大约200美元。你们买了吗？没有。
We said, quote, a smaller finale.
We settled on this cube with a dinosaur on it.
It was supposed to have 10 shots inside.
He said it would be good.
We had the kids arrange everything in an order.
We started with the chicken.
It was lame as expected.
Small tank was lank.
我们说，“来个小一点的压轴吧。”我们选了这个带恐龙图案的方块。里面应该有10发子弹。他说这会很不错。我们让孩子们按顺序把所有东西排好。我们从“小鸡”开始。如预期般逊色。小坦克很弱，
lame, medium tank was cool. The exploding blue balls was fun surprise. Slurpy was awesome.
That's what she said.
It's very funny. Slurpy was awesome. The fountains were fountains. Then we set up dino box.
I would like to repeat that this box was small. Like imagine if a softball was a cube. You could hold it in one hand for sure.
I think we're expecting like 10 smallish fireworks to fly up one by one overhead.
and explode, kind of like bottle rockets, but a little better. Dear Lord, this thing was like a tiny
professional fireworks show in a cube. And it wasn't 10 of the same thing either. It was this intense
variety of different giant fireworks shooting into the air literally right above us. It was completely
中型坦克很酷。爆炸的蓝色球是个有趣的惊喜。思乐冰太棒了。这就是她说的。非常有趣。思乐冰太棒了。喷泉就是喷泉。然后我们设置了恐龙方块。我想重复一下，这个方块很小。就像想象一个垒球那么大的立方体。你肯定能单手拿住它。我想我们期待的是大约10个小烟花一个接一个地飞向空中爆炸，有点像二踢脚，但稍微好一点。天哪，这玩意儿就像一个小型的专业烟花秀塞在一个方块里。而且也不是10个一样的东西。这是各种不同巨大烟花在空中剧烈绽放的组合，就在我们的头顶上方。这完全是
unexpected and a great finale. Awesome. That's great. All right. Final Lake Day, everybody.
Our final full day at the lake was a big success. My mom and sister made it back to hope.
house in the morning. It was a Wednesday and they were in fact open as the sign suggested. My mom dropped
off her donations and got my dad a nice summer shirt. She loves a good find. We rented a wave runner and hosted
everyone at our place. My folks brought over a bunch of lunch stuff and a cooler and drinks and we
basically camped out on our dock all day. I should mention that the one drawback to our rental is that
the house is up high on a hill. There are multiple levels of decks leading down to the water.
and lots and lots and lots of stairs. Once you get down there, you only want to go back to the
出乎意料，而且是一个绝佳的压轴。太棒了。太棒了。好的。湖畔最后一天，各位。我们在湖畔的最后一个完整的一天取得了巨大成功。我妈妈和妹妹早上去了希望之家。那是星期三，而且如招牌所示，他们确实开门了。我妈妈送去了捐赠物，并给我爸爸买了一件好看的夏衬衫。她喜欢淘到好东西。我们租了一台水上摩托艇，并在我们这里招待了所有人。我父母带了一堆午餐用品、一个冰柜和饮料，我们基本上整天都在我们的码头上露营。我应该提一下，我们租的房子唯一的缺点是它建在山坡高处。有多层露台通往水边，
house if you absolutely need something. There are so many stairs you might consider pooping in the
lake. Thankfully, it never came to that, but I'm just saying it was a climb. We tried hard to have
everything we needed down on the dock. When we did need something from the house, I'd volunteer to go
and get it as I decided that the stairs and treading water were my two chances at exercise during this trip.
All day long, we basically took turns riding the wave runner and swimming.
Our doc also had a diving platform that the kids loved.
Lots of near heart attacks for me watching them flip and dive off that thing.
In the evening, we ordered takeout and watched the USA World Cup game together.
还有非常、非常、非常多的台阶。一旦你下去了，除非绝对需要什么东西，否则你根本不想再回屋里去。有太多的台阶，你甚至会考虑直接在湖里拉屎。谢准没到那一步，但我只是说那真是一次攀爬。我们努力确保我们需要的一切都在码头上。当我们确实需要屋里的东西时，我会自愿去拿，因为我决定这些台阶和在水中踩水是我这次旅行中仅有的两次锻炼机会。整整一天，我们基本上轮流骑水上摩托艇和游泳。我们的码头还有一个跳水平台，孩子们非常喜欢。看着他们在那个东西上翻转和跳水，我差点心脏病发作。傍晚时分，我们叫了外卖，一起观看了美国队的世界杯比赛。
Me and my folks sat outside on the covered patio and watched the outside TV.
They weren't super interested in the game,
so it gave me a good chance to ask some questions and get the scoop on the lakehouse and how it came about.
I found out my memory was mostly correct.
They bought the land when I was eight years old, and it took a year to build.
My dad told me he especially liked that the house faced west.
He wanted to sit on the deck in the mornings and have coffee without the sun in his eyes.
Since this is literally one of my favorite things to do at the lake, I love knowing that detail.
我和我父母坐在外面带顶的露台上面对室外的电视。他们对这场比赛不是特别感兴趣，这给了我一个好机会问一些问题，并了解有关湖屋及其来历的内幕。我发现我的记忆基本没错。他们在我八岁时买下了这块地，花了一年时间建造。我爸爸告诉我，他特别喜欢这座房子朝西。他想早上坐在露台上喝咖啡，而阳光不会刺眼。既然这简直是我在湖边最喜欢的事情之一，我很高兴得知这个细节。
He also told me the man they hired to build the house was a drunk and they got into a ton of fights.
He would set a meeting with my dad.
My dad would drive three hours from St. Louis, and then the guy would be late and reek of booze.
It caused a lot of problems.
At one point, they got into such a huge argument, the man threatened to burn the house down.
Oh, my goodness.
Crazy.
In other news, we met the neighbor next door to our rental.
他还告诉我，他们雇来建房子的那个男人是个酒鬼，他们吵了很多次架。他会和我爸爸定好开会时间。我爸爸从圣路易斯开车三个小时过来，然后那家伙会迟到并且浑身酒气。这引发了很多问题。有一次，他们吵得那么厉害，那家伙威胁要把房子烧了。哦，天哪。太疯狂了。另外，我们遇到了我们租的房子隔壁的邻居。
I mentioned that he had some stray cats living under his porch and that we'd been feeding them.
I offered to give him our leftover food if he'd like to keep feeding them, and he said his wife already feeds them.
We were so excited to hear this.
He said last year, they rescued four kittens and took them back to their family farm.
He also said he thinks they're all coming from this one house down the road.
that doesn't fix their cats.
He really wants to try and trap the ones at his house and get them fixed and then re-release them.
He said, quote, they're good at getting critters.
I mentioned that he had some stray cats living under his porch and that we'd been feeding them. I offered to give him our leftover food if he'd like to keep feeding them, and he said his wife already feeds them. We were so excited to hear this. He said last year, they rescued four kittens and took them back to their family farm. He also said he thinks they're all coming from this one house down the road. that doesn't fix their cats. He really wants to try and trap the ones at his house and get them fixed and then re-release them. He said, quote, they're good at getting critters.
Lady, this must have made you so happy because she does the rescue work that you do?
Yes, I wrote, we are not going to have to worry about these kitties.
What a relief.
It was really weighing on us this whole trip.
Are these kittens going to be okay?
We played our final round of celebrity.
It was our tiebreaker game and the girls won.
It was really super close.
Lady, this must have made you so happy because she does the rescue work that you do? Yes, I wrote, we are not going to have to worry about these kitties. What a relief. It was really weighing on us this whole trip. Are these kittens going to be okay? We played our final round of celebrity. It was our tiebreaker game and the girls won. It was really super close.
54 to 51, some impressive gameplay and some hilarious clues.
I was quite fond of Harper's Clue, quote,
first name is the name of my principal at school.
The last name is crispy meat.
Kevin Bacon.
In this round, there were multiple Rin Tintins and Taylor Swift's.
Oh, by the way, we are pretty sure we are about to share a wedding anniversary
with Taylor and Travis on July 3rd.
54 to 51, some impressive gameplay and some hilarious clues. I was quite fond of Harper's Clue, quote, first name is the name of my principal at school. The last name is crispy meat. Kevin Bacon. In this round, there were multiple Rin Tintins and Taylor Swift's. Oh, by the way, we are pretty sure we are about to share a wedding anniversary with Taylor and Travis on July 3rd.
This year, it will be 16 years for me and Lee.
she is at Madison Square Garden with 1,000 guests, I'll be on a southwest flight that connects in Phoenix.
Thankfully, I won't be flying with three stray cats, but I will be with my sweet family that I love with all my heart and filled with wonderful lake memories.
I can't wait until next year. That was fantastic. You're a really good writer. I realized during you saying this,
what I like about these travel journals, it's such a good snapshot of the person writing them.
And that three minutes we'd have spent together sums you up perfectly as a person, like what you like, animals, comfort, family, but with a little bit of snark.
But there's like a nice just out of reach, but it's not coming out unless you deserve.
Thank you.
This year, it will be 16 years for me and Lee. she is at Madison Square Garden with 1,000 guests, I'll be on a southwest flight that connects in Phoenix. Thankfully, I won't be flying with three stray cats, but I will be with my sweet family that I love with all my heart and filled with wonderful lake memories. I can't wait until next year. That was fantastic. You're a really good writer. I realized during you saying this, what I like about these travel journals, it's such a good snapshot of the person writing them. And that three minutes we'd have spent together sums you up perfectly as a person, like what you like, animals, comfort, family, but with a little bit of snark. But there's like a nice just out of reach, but it's not coming out unless you deserve. Thank you.
Yeah.
And also, like, your eye for detail is fantastic.
And also you get a real sense that you do like a plan.
like you would not have gone to the thrift store on a Tuesday.
You would have looked it up.
You would have confirmed that it was open before you got in the car.
Of course.
Also, knowing that my mom had planned it,
Yeah. And also, like, your eye for detail is fantastic. And also you get a real sense that you do like a plan. like you would not have gone to the thrift store on a Tuesday. You would have looked it up. You would have confirmed that it was open before you got in the car. Of course. Also, knowing that my mom had planned it,
I would double check those plans.
And my sister is the type she's so go with the flow.
She would never even think to question whether or not this place was actually open
during the week of July 4th, no less.
Yeah.
It reminded me of who's the artist that did the Saturday evening posts for years that
painter.
Norman Rockwell.
I would double check those plans. And my sister is the type she's so go with the flow. She would never even think to question whether or not this place was actually open during the week of July 4th, no less. Yeah. It reminded me of who's the artist that did the Saturday evening posts for years that painter. Norman Rockwell.
There's a very Norman Rockwell-esque picture you just painted.
Yeah.
I was going to say this sounds like such a great tradition in all-American family
vacation that I really want to go to there.
It just sounds so nice and fun.
Yeah.
I feel like it's one of the things that we bond over to is like some of the shares you
have about your dad and then DIY and all that.
There's a very Norman Rockwell-esque picture you just painted. Yeah. I was going to say this sounds like such a great tradition in all-American family vacation that I really want to go to there. It just sounds so nice and fun. Yeah. I feel like it's one of the things that we bond over to is like some of the shares you have about your dad and then DIY and all that.
That's very much my experience on the farm, you know, with my parents and what that
land meant to them. Yeah, I loved it. My parents were always happiest at Lake of the Ozarks.
They were relaxed. It's their happy place. And so it's really important for me to experience them
in that place each year. With your kids, too. With my kids. Yeah. Yeah, my dad driving the boat on that.
Yeah. Well, Matt, I feel like a camping trip is pretty quintessential American vacation.
Yeah, a little different spin on it, but it's related for sure. Well, tell us about your
trip. Okay, I wrote a little short piece. Oh, let's hear it. Okay. This past weekend, I received a last
minute invitation from two friends to go on a bikepacking adventure, which is a cross between biking and
That's very much my experience on the farm, you know, with my parents and what that land meant to them. Yeah, I loved it. My parents were always happiest at Lake of the Ozarks. They were relaxed. It's their happy place. And so it's really important for me to experience them in that place each year. With your kids, too. With my kids. Yeah. Yeah, my dad driving the boat on that. Yeah. Well, Matt, I feel like a camping trip is pretty quintessential American vacation. Yeah, a little different spin on it, but it's related for sure. Well, tell us about your trip. Okay, I wrote a little short piece. Oh, let's hear it. Okay. This past weekend, I received a last minute invitation from two friends to go on a bikepacking adventure, which is a cross between biking and
backpacking, where you load up all your camping gear on a big mountain bike and head out into the wilderness.
I was up for the challenge and said yes to the dress. Big shout out to my wife Casey for staying back
and watching the children while I tested my medal in this way. The goal was to bike around 100 miles and
three days with lots of uphill climbing under the blazing sun. It became clear pretty early on that
I was the weakest link by far. I was trailing my group and riding solo pretty much the entire time.
While they were way up ahead talking about bikes, gear, and other endurance challenges, I was far in the
rear. However, I was having the absolute T of my L, taking on a different, some would say even harder
challenge, singing every part of Le Miserab word for word. I think my finest work was,
backpacking, where you load up all your camping gear on a big mountain bike and head out into the wilderness. I was up for the challenge and said yes to the dress. Big shout out to my wife Casey for staying back and watching the children while I tested my medal in this way. The goal was to bike around 100 miles and three days with lots of uphill climbing under the blazing sun. It became clear pretty early on that I was the weakest link by far. I was trailing my group and riding solo pretty much the entire time. While they were way up ahead talking about bikes, gear, and other endurance challenges, I was far in the rear. However, I was having the absolute T of my L, taking on a different, some would say even harder challenge, singing every part of Le Miserab word for word. I think my finest work was,
was the confrontation scene between Javert and John Valjean.
Oh, that's my favorite song.
It's the best.
You were singing while you were riding the bike?
I mean, you know, kind of a memory in my head.
I would have no air.
You and I relax in very different ways, Matt.
This is so many tasks.
was the confrontation scene between Javert and John Valjean. Oh, that's my favorite song. It's the best. You were singing while you were riding the bike? I mean, you know, kind of a memory in my head. I would have no air. You and I relax in very different ways, Matt. This is so many tasks.
We climbed mountains, descended long dusty trails,
jumped in mountain lakes and slept out under the stars with no cell phone service
and without seeing a car or another soul for miles.
While peddling, I found myself wondering who from the office ladies' crew would also take on this rugged experience, sleeping on the ground, only packing one pair of underwear for three days, going to the bathroom in a hole in the ground.
I mean, I think if my journal where I went on and on about my mattress is any indication, I think it's not me.
Sam, 100%. Sam would probably leave this recording with me right now to go bikepacking.
True.
Angela, I think, would enjoy all the time in nature.
We climbed mountains, descended long dusty trails, jumped in mountain lakes and slept out under the stars with no cell phone service and without seeing a car or another soul for miles. While peddling, I found myself wondering who from the office ladies' crew would also take on this rugged experience, sleeping on the ground, only packing one pair of underwear for three days, going to the bathroom in a hole in the ground. I mean, I think if my journal where I went on and on about my mattress is any indication, I think it's not me. Sam, 100%. Sam would probably leave this recording with me right now to go bikepacking. True. Angela, I think, would enjoy all the time in nature.
but miss the comforts of home.
I would love all the time in nature.
I would hate being on the bicycle.
It always hurts me privies.
If you could be in a side car being paddled, that'd be perfect.
Yes.
I would navigate from a side car.
Okay.
but miss the comforts of home. I would love all the time in nature. I would hate being on the bicycle. It always hurts me privies. If you could be in a side car being paddled, that'd be perfect. Yes. I would navigate from a side car. Okay.
Jenna, I could really see going either way.
She said she gets creeped out being in nature for too long,
but I think she might enjoy the hardcore challenge element of this experience.
You're right about that.
There's a part of me that does like to push myself.
Yeah, what's the line from the edge, what one man can do.
Another can do.
We completed our ride, and I found bike packing to be a pretty apt metaphor for life.
Jenna, I could really see going either way. She said she gets creeped out being in nature for too long, but I think she might enjoy the hardcore challenge element of this experience. You're right about that. There's a part of me that does like to push myself. Yeah, what's the line from the edge, what one man can do. Another can do. We completed our ride, and I found bike packing to be a pretty apt metaphor for life.
There were hills and valleys, moments of pure joy, intense struggle, and also many of just pedaling through it.
You'll laugh, you'll cry, and your undercarriage will be sore and chapped most of the time.
Exactly.
But at the end of the day, it's all about taking care of others, yourself, and our planet.
Peace and love, Matt, senior producer, office ladies.
I love the official sign-off in your journal.
You signed that like you weren't coming back in case somebody found your body.
Sam, there was moments when I wasn't sure if I was coming back.
There were hills and valleys, moments of pure joy, intense struggle, and also many of just pedaling through it. You'll laugh, you'll cry, and your undercarriage will be sore and chapped most of the time. Exactly. But at the end of the day, it's all about taking care of others, yourself, and our planet. Peace and love, Matt, senior producer, office ladies. I love the official sign-off in your journal. You signed that like you weren't coming back in case somebody found your body. Sam, there was moments when I wasn't sure if I was coming back.
Wow, what a trip.
That's amazing.
I love it.
Yeah.
All right, well, should we take a break?
And then we'll be back, Angela, with your Wimbledon share.
And Sam is going to share about Germany.
Yeah, we both went abroad.
Wow, what a trip. That's amazing. I love it. Yeah. All right, well, should we take a break? And then we'll be back, Angela, with your Wimbledon share. And Sam is going to share about Germany. Yeah, we both went abroad.
Yeah.
All right.
We are back and I have been waiting a few weeks to hear about your trip to Wimbledon.
I can wait no longer.
I'm on the edge of my seat.
You guys, I made her go second because I knew this was the journal.
Yeah, yeah, you can't follow this.
I don't think so.
Yeah. All right. We are back and I have been waiting a few weeks to hear about your trip to Wimbledon. I can wait no longer. I'm on the edge of my seat. You guys, I made her go second because I knew this was the journal. Yeah, yeah, you can't follow this. I don't think so.
Jenna's and Matt's were both wonderful.
I don't think it's that interesting, but I'm going to read it.
First of all, I want you guys to know I've been to London many times and I did a semester abroad
in college in London.
So I didn't need to do a ton of tourist stuff.
This was really about seeing my friends,
hanging out with my friends that live there,
and then ending the trip with us all going to Wimbledon.
Jenna's and Matt's were both wonderful. I don't think it's that interesting, but I'm going to read it. First of all, I want you guys to know I've been to London many times and I did a semester abroad in college in London. So I didn't need to do a ton of tourist stuff. This was really about seeing my friends, hanging out with my friends that live there, and then ending the trip with us all going to Wimbledon.
So anyway, just thought I would preface that.
Okay.
All right.
This is titled AK Travel Journal.
Okay.
I don't know why I felt the need to title it.
And here it goes.
Tuesday, June 30th, 1130 a.m.
So anyway, just thought I would preface that. Okay. All right. This is titled AK Travel Journal. Okay. I don't know why I felt the need to title it. And here it goes. Tuesday, June 30th, 1130 a.m.
On the way to the airport.
So excited.
Woohoo!
We are behind a 1990s silver Toyota Corolla
that has pinstriping that says,
Yoki Mobile.
How much do you have to love Yoki to pinstripe it on your car?
Hi from the TSA line.
On the way to the airport. So excited. Woohoo! We are behind a 1990s silver Toyota Corolla that has pinstriping that says, Yoki Mobile. How much do you have to love Yoki to pinstripe it on your car? Hi from the TSA line.
So we play this game with our kids when we travel where we share things you over here as you walk past someone.
This started a few years back on a trip to New York City.
A big city is great for this game because you hear crazy snippets of people's conversations as you walk past them on the street.
But it is also fun at airports.
Here's one of those moments from my walk through LAX.
This man had two suitcases and he was hauling ass to try to get to the front of the security line before this big group got there.
Trailing behind him carrying a big bag was his wife.
She was clearly annoyed at his brisk pace and she said, Gary, can you slow your roll?
So we play this game with our kids when we travel where we share things you over here as you walk past someone. This started a few years back on a trip to New York City. A big city is great for this game because you hear crazy snippets of people's conversations as you walk past them on the street. But it is also fun at airports. Here's one of those moments from my walk through LAX. This man had two suitcases and he was hauling ass to try to get to the front of the security line before this big group got there. Trailing behind him carrying a big bag was his wife. She was clearly annoyed at his brisk pace and she said, Gary, can you slow your roll?
That cracked me up.
2 p.m. at the airport lounge, baby.
This is a bucket list trip for me.
So I went all out.
my miles and I'm flying business class.
Ooh la la. I still can't believe I'm going to Wimbledon.
Two exclamation points.
I can't remember a summer where I didn't watch Wimbledon with my mom.
That cracked me up. 2 p.m. at the airport lounge, baby. This is a bucket list trip for me. So I went all out. my miles and I'm flying business class. Ooh la la. I still can't believe I'm going to Wimbledon. Two exclamation points. I can't remember a summer where I didn't watch Wimbledon with my mom.
It's her favorite tennis tournament.
We have always dreamed of going together.
We have spent countless hours in front of the TV watching all the matches.
We would make ourselves cups of tea and eat strawberries and pretend we were there.
I have so many favorite moments like when Beyond Borg beat John McEnroe and he dropped to his
knees on the grass, or the many times Serena Williams won and would pump her fists like,
hell yeah. One of my mom's favorite players was Kim Kleisters. We loved watching her play, and this is
where life gets really crazy. And as I write this, I still can't believe it, but I met Kim Kleisters
It's her favorite tennis tournament. We have always dreamed of going together. We have spent countless hours in front of the TV watching all the matches. We would make ourselves cups of tea and eat strawberries and pretend we were there. I have so many favorite moments like when Beyond Borg beat John McEnroe and he dropped to his knees on the grass, or the many times Serena Williams won and would pump her fists like, hell yeah. One of my mom's favorite players was Kim Kleisters. We loved watching her play, and this is where life gets really crazy. And as I write this, I still can't believe it, but I met Kim Kleisters
last year at the International Tennis Hall of Fame. She is one of the nicest, most wonderful people,
not to mention one of the greats in tennis history. We have stayed in touch over the past year and
have become friends.
Ah!
Exclamation point.
Isn't that crazy?
My mom and I both still can't believe it.
I shared with Kim, our love of Wimbledon,
last year at the International Tennis Hall of Fame. She is one of the nicest, most wonderful people, not to mention one of the greats in tennis history. We have stayed in touch over the past year and have become friends. Ah! Exclamation point. Isn't that crazy? My mom and I both still can't believe it. I shared with Kim, our love of Wimbledon,
and she offered to help me get tickets.
I about fell on the floor.
Getting tickets to Wimbledon is really difficult.
I've never been able to.
I called my mom immediately.
She was so excited, and I asked her to go with me.
We had a really long conversation.
You know, my mom turned 88 this year,
and she offered to help me get tickets. I about fell on the floor. Getting tickets to Wimbledon is really difficult. I've never been able to. I called my mom immediately. She was so excited, and I asked her to go with me. We had a really long conversation. You know, my mom turned 88 this year,
and she shared with me that long travel days are just too much for her now.
But she told me I absolutely had to go.
She said I had to go for the both of us.
And I had orders to take a ton of pictures and call her every day.
So, this is going to make me cry.
Here I sit in the airport lounge, texting my mom and wearing a necklace,
that my dad bought her in the 70s.
He knew her love of tennis.
and she shared with me that long travel days are just too much for her now. But she told me I absolutely had to go. She said I had to go for the both of us. And I had orders to take a ton of pictures and call her every day. So, this is going to make me cry. Here I sit in the airport lounge, texting my mom and wearing a necklace, that my dad bought her in the 70s. He knew her love of tennis.
And it's a string of tiny gold interlocking.
King tennis rackets. My mom gave it to me after he passed away, and I knew I had to wear it on this
trip. So I'm going to hold her and my dad close to my heart as I go on this adventure.
We both were bumping up against our parents' age and limitations and our awareness of that
on our trips. Yes. Yeah. It was so thrilling to get these tickets and also better sweet
that my mom wasn't with me, but she was.
Yeah.
Okay.
And it's a string of tiny gold interlocking. King tennis rackets. My mom gave it to me after he passed away, and I knew I had to wear it on this trip. So I'm going to hold her and my dad close to my heart as I go on this adventure. We both were bumping up against our parents' age and limitations and our awareness of that on our trips. Yes. Yeah. It was so thrilling to get these tickets and also better sweet that my mom wasn't with me, but she was. Yeah. Okay.
Sorry, I needed to wipe the tears.
And now, are you ready for a hard pivot?
There had clearly been a passage in time,
because here's my next entry.
Ready?
Okay.
Oh, Lord.
The man next to me took off his shoes.
Sorry, I needed to wipe the tears. And now, are you ready for a hard pivot? There had clearly been a passage in time, because here's my next entry. Ready? Okay. Oh, Lord. The man next to me took off his shoes.
Why?
Oh, God.
Now he's taking off his socks.
I might move.
Need snacks, BRB.
Move seats and got some type of spicy nut mix.
So, family update.
Josh and Kate are going to a volleyball tournament this week.
Why? Oh, God. Now he's taking off his socks. I might move. Need snacks, BRB. Move seats and got some type of spicy nut mix. So, family update. Josh and Kate are going to a volleyball tournament this week.
Isabel and Jack are taking college courses over the summer.
So this is the first time I'll be taking a big trip by myself.
I feel a little rusty at doing this solo.
Sidebar.
They are not playing Wimbledon in the lounge, WTF.
There are so many TVs, but all they're showing is the World Cup.
And look, I get it, okay?
The World Cup is amazing and fun.
Isabel and Jack are taking college courses over the summer. So this is the first time I'll be taking a big trip by myself. I feel a little rusty at doing this solo. Sidebar. They are not playing Wimbledon in the lounge, WTF. There are so many TVs, but all they're showing is the World Cup. And look, I get it, okay? The World Cup is amazing and fun.
And I love it, too.
But not one TV for the biggest tennis tournament.
of the year, not one?
Getting a glass of wine, finding out the Wi-Fi, please hold.
That's very grumpy.
Okay, I'm back with wine, and I'm watching Wimbledon on my laptop.
I am trying to take a selfie of myself in the lounge with my wine and tennis on my
computer to send it to my mom, but I couldn't figure it out.
And I love it, too. But not one TV for the biggest tennis tournament. of the year, not one? Getting a glass of wine, finding out the Wi-Fi, please hold. That's very grumpy. Okay, I'm back with wine, and I'm watching Wimbledon on my laptop. I am trying to take a selfie of myself in the lounge with my wine and tennis on my computer to send it to my mom, but I couldn't figure it out.
I'm not bendy enough to fit it all in the picture.
A very nice gentleman asked if I needed him to take the picture because I probably
look so awkward.
I'm slightly embarrassed.
4 p.m.
British Airways Flight, 282, L-A-X to London, Heathrow.
Okay, I need to be snarky.
My flight attendant is 100% in Angela Martin.
I'm not bendy enough to fit it all in the picture. A very nice gentleman asked if I needed him to take the picture because I probably look so awkward. I'm slightly embarrassed. 4 p.m. British Airways Flight, 282, L-A-X to London, Heathrow. Okay, I need to be snarky. My flight attendant is 100% in Angela Martin.
Severe blonde bun, so bossy.
She's snippy with everyone, and she's also a little gossipy.
I was in line for the bathroom, and she was looking at a passenger
and whispering to another flight attendant, and then they both started laughing.
I'm trying to figure out who they're talking about.
Maybe the man with the skeleton socks.
He does seem annoying.
I had the beet goat cheese salad. I really liked it. And then I watched the movie Midwinter Break. So good. This movie deals with traumatic moments that shape us, marriage ups and downs, and the calling to be of greater service through our faith. It also does a great job of showing that life happens in crowded spaces, sadness, anger, heartbreak. It can all happen over dinner at a restaurant with tons of people around. There is only one sex scene in this movie and barely that.
Severe blonde bun, so bossy. She's snippy with everyone, and she's also a little gossipy. I was in line for the bathroom, and she was looking at a passenger and whispering to another flight attendant, and then they both started laughing. I'm trying to figure out who they're talking about. Maybe the man with the skeleton socks. He does seem annoying. I had the beet goat cheese salad. I really liked it. And then I watched the movie Midwinter Break. So good. This movie deals with traumatic moments that shape us, marriage ups and downs, and the calling to be of greater service through our faith. It also does a great job of showing that life happens in crowded spaces, sadness, anger, heartbreak. It can all happen over dinner at a restaurant with tons of people around. There is only one sex scene in this movie and barely that.
Like you don't see anything.
It's just a bunch of sheets.
It's between two older people.
Maybe they're in their late 60s, early 70s.
And that is the moment when a dad from our kids school walked up to me to say hi.
I paused the TV and it's two old people barely clothed in bed together.
The dad from the school said, what are you watching?
Cringe.
Like you don't see anything. It's just a bunch of sheets. It's between two older people. Maybe they're in their late 60s, early 70s. And that is the moment when a dad from our kids school walked up to me to say hi. I paused the TV and it's two old people barely clothed in bed together. The dad from the school said, what are you watching? Cringe.
July 1st, 1030 a.m.
I just landed at London Heathrow.
It's the day after I left L.A. and I barely slept on the plane. I'm not sure how I'm going to stay awake.
In my taxi now, the driver's an older man, and he said, where to, love? His name is Andy,
and I told him my name was Angela, and he said, we're the two A's. I love him. Traffic getting from the airport to my friend's
flat and high gate was really bad, but I didn't mind. I was tired and the taxi had air conditioning.
I was almost asleep, and Andy said, you might get to see the royal family, so I parked up. On the other side of the freeway,
a bunch of police on motorcycles clearing the way for a vehicle motorcade.
July 1st, 1030 a.m. I just landed at London Heathrow. It's the day after I left L.A. and I barely slept on the plane. I'm not sure how I'm going to stay awake. In my taxi now, the driver's an older man, and he said, where to, love? His name is Andy, and I told him my name was Angela, and he said, we're the two A's. I love him. Traffic getting from the airport to my friend's flat and high gate was really bad, but I didn't mind. I was tired and the taxi had air conditioning. I was almost asleep, and Andy said, you might get to see the royal family, so I parked up. On the other side of the freeway, a bunch of police on motorcycles clearing the way for a vehicle motorcade.
Then three big black SUVs came whizzing by.
Andy said, that's one of the royals.
And then he said, they'll never know what it's like to sit in traffic.
I asked him who he thought it was, and he said, maybe the king.
Andy said the king goes back and forth to London and then to High Grove so he can, quote,
smell his flowers.
I feel like Andy was throwing subtle shade.
Andy and I might be related.
Then three big black SUVs came whizzing by. Andy said, that's one of the royals. And then he said, they'll never know what it's like to sit in traffic. I asked him who he thought it was, and he said, maybe the king. Andy said the king goes back and forth to London and then to High Grove so he can, quote, smell his flowers. I feel like Andy was throwing subtle shade. Andy and I might be related.
July 2nd, I'm staying at my friends in Highgate.
We walked a ton yesterday.
My friend Betsy says that is the best way to stay awake and fight off jet lag.
Step count, I can't remember, but it was over 17,000.
Today we took the tube to Marleybone to meet up with Betsy's friends, Louise and Marina,
for what they call fancy lunch.
So here's what you do for fancy lunch.
First, you meet for tea and biscuits.
July 2nd, I'm staying at my friends in Highgate. We walked a ton yesterday. My friend Betsy says that is the best way to stay awake and fight off jet lag. Step count, I can't remember, but it was over 17,000. Today we took the tube to Marleybone to meet up with Betsy's friends, Louise and Marina, for what they call fancy lunch. So here's what you do for fancy lunch. First, you meet for tea and biscuits.
Then you do some shopping, and then you have a fancy lunch.
It was fantastic.
I loved it.
Then we went back to Highgate to play tennis at the park.
Yes, you guys, I brought my racket all the way to London.
Step count today was crazy around 19,000.
July 3rd, I have now played tennis twice in London.
I think I'm ready for Wimbledon.
Then you do some shopping, and then you have a fancy lunch. It was fantastic. I loved it. Then we went back to Highgate to play tennis at the park. Yes, you guys, I brought my racket all the way to London. Step count today was crazy around 19,000. July 3rd, I have now played tennis twice in London. I think I'm ready for Wimbledon.
Ha, ha.
More walking today.
Things I took pictures of.
Flowers by the street, lots of hanging flowers, window box flowers, and hydrangees.
So beautiful.
Also, I took pictures of ivy that grows on the same.
size of buildings.
I am driving my friends nuts because I keep stopping to take pictures of flowers.
Ha, ha. More walking today. Things I took pictures of. Flowers by the street, lots of hanging flowers, window box flowers, and hydrangees. So beautiful. Also, I took pictures of ivy that grows on the same. size of buildings. I am driving my friends nuts because I keep stopping to take pictures of flowers.
Last night we walked through a park and Mumford and Sons was playing a concert.
There was a giant fence and we could hear them from the other side.
There were a lot of people that I guess didn't get tickets or were just enjoying the
concert from outside on the lawn, having wine and picnics.
We hung out there for a bit and heard the end of the concert.
It was a lovely night.
Step count was around 20,000.
July 4th.
Last night we walked through a park and Mumford and Sons was playing a concert. There was a giant fence and we could hear them from the other side. There were a lot of people that I guess didn't get tickets or were just enjoying the concert from outside on the lawn, having wine and picnics. We hung out there for a bit and heard the end of the concert. It was a lovely night. Step count was around 20,000. July 4th.
All my tennis gals have now arrived.
The four of us will be going to Wimbledon together.
I saw a reel on Instagram that says every group of four friends on a trip has a navigator,
a planner, and two that don't know anything.
Well, I think for us, Betsy is the planner.
Rebecca actually likes to navigate and figure out all the trains and routes.
She told me she enjoys it.
Thank God, because I hate it.
All my tennis gals have now arrived. The four of us will be going to Wimbledon together. I saw a reel on Instagram that says every group of four friends on a trip has a navigator, a planner, and two that don't know anything. Well, I think for us, Betsy is the planner. Rebecca actually likes to navigate and figure out all the trains and routes. She told me she enjoys it. Thank God, because I hate it.
Julie is the responsible one who makes sure we all have the things we need,
and I am the historian.
I take all the pictures and document the trip
and sometimes drive everyone crazy in the process,
but they're always happy after the fact to have the pictures.
And you guys know I'm going to scrapbook.
Yes.
My next entry is,
Julie is the responsible one who makes sure we all have the things we need, and I am the historian. I take all the pictures and document the trip and sometimes drive everyone crazy in the process, but they're always happy after the fact to have the pictures. And you guys know I'm going to scrapbook. Yes. My next entry is,
we are now at an Airbnb near Marble Arch.
This morning we were walking to the tube station near us
and there was a big truck going down the street
and a man was leaning out of the back of it
with a special type of water hose.
It looked like a long pole,
but then it had a bend at the end and a nozzle.
He was using it to,
we are now at an Airbnb near Marble Arch. This morning we were walking to the tube station near us and there was a big truck going down the street and a man was leaning out of the back of it with a special type of water hose. It looked like a long pole, but then it had a bend at the end and a nozzle. He was using it to,
water the flower pots that hang from the lamp post. I cannot tell you how happy that made me to see
them being watered and cared for. I bet you could guess it, but I took a picture.
1B.m. walked through a beautiful park today, and there was a cafe where you could get snacks,
ice cream, and also buy plants. I am in heaven. I took a picture of the sign, Pavilion Cafe.
And then as we walked through the park, there was a game of cricket going on, so we sat on a bench
and watched for a while.
I also fell in love with a floppy Dotson named Peanut.
I would love a floppy Dotson.
water the flower pots that hang from the lamp post. I cannot tell you how happy that made me to see them being watered and cared for. I bet you could guess it, but I took a picture. 1B.m. walked through a beautiful park today, and there was a cafe where you could get snacks, ice cream, and also buy plants. I am in heaven. I took a picture of the sign, Pavilion Cafe. And then as we walked through the park, there was a game of cricket going on, so we sat on a bench and watched for a while. I also fell in love with a floppy Dotson named Peanut. I would love a floppy Dotson.
I love any type of dog that looks like a big burrito.
3 p.m. went to the department store Liberty.
It's so beautiful.
It was founded in 1875.
It's several floors tall in an old Tudor style building.
I love the wooden staircase and the ceiling.
I bought a cute summer robe with a navy floral design.
Step count today was crazy.
I love any type of dog that looks like a big burrito. 3 p.m. went to the department store Liberty. It's so beautiful. It was founded in 1875. It's several floors tall in an old Tudor style building. I love the wooden staircase and the ceiling. I bought a cute summer robe with a navy floral design. Step count today was crazy.
23,102.
My watch says I climbed 25 flights of stairs.
Wow.
I know.
You haven't even gotten to Wimbledon yet.
I forgot that's where this is headed.
July 5th, 11 p.m.
23,102. My watch says I climbed 25 flights of stairs. Wow. I know. You haven't even gotten to Wimbledon yet. I know. I forgot that's where this is headed. July 5th, 11 p.m.
So tired.
But I wanted to jot down about my day.
I bought a tin full of tea with Queen Elizabeth's face on it.
There were a bunch of different royal family members' faces on tins of tea to choose from,
but I went with Queen Elizabeth.
I also bought a cute tote bag for Isabel and a Christmas ornament.
I always buy an ornament from our travels, and the kids love it.
So this year we'll be adding a little figurine of Paddington the Bear to the tree.
So tired. But I wanted to jot down about my day. I bought a tin full of tea with Queen Elizabeth's face on it. There were a bunch of different royal family members' faces on tins of tea to choose from, but I went with Queen Elizabeth. I also bought a cute tote bag for Isabel and a Christmas ornament. I always buy an ornament from our travels, and the kids love it. So this year we'll be adding a little figurine of Paddington the Bear to the tree.
Oh, and I also went to see the play adaptation of my neighbor Totero.
I loved it.
I teared up at the end when the cast and puppeteers took their bow.
We all stood on our feet and applauded them.
It's what I love about theater or making TV or film.
So many people behind the scenes that come together to make a piece of art.
It's truly moving.
July 6th, 8 a.m.
Oh, and I also went to see the play adaptation of my neighbor Totero. I loved it. I teared up at the end when the cast and puppeteers took their bow. We all stood on our feet and applauded them. It's what I love about theater or making TV or film. So many people behind the scenes that come together to make a piece of art. It's truly moving. July 6th, 8 a.m.
drinking my tea and steaming my dress.
Today, I feel like that moment when Michael Scott was screaming,
oh my God, it's happening.
Today is Wimbledon.
Ah!
I'm so excited.
No time to journal.
Must get ready.
drinking my tea and steaming my dress. Today, I feel like that moment when Michael Scott was screaming, oh my God, it's happening. Today is Wimbledon. Ah! I'm so excited. No time to journal. Must get ready.
Also, my travel steamer is fantastic and tiny and folds up.
It's by a company called NextDoo.
Okay, I felt like that was important to share.
Okay.
July 7th.
Good morning.
I woke up early.
I couldn't sleep.
Also, my travel steamer is fantastic and tiny and folds up. It's by a company called NextDoo. Okay, I felt like that was important to share. Okay. July 7th. Good morning. I woke up early. I couldn't sleep.
I stayed up late with the time difference,
talking to my mom to tell her every.
detail of my day at Wimbledon. She was thrilled. Yesterday was one of the best days of my life. I don't even
know where to begin. I took a ton of pictures and jotted things down on my notes app so I could share in my
journal. Let's start with my outfit. Fit check. I wore a green linen dress by Bowden and comfy
white sneakers with a green trim by Viva. I don't know how to say it. And then I also brought a tote
bag with an empty water bottle because you can refill it once you get inside sunscreen and a hat.
very important.
I stayed up late with the time difference, talking to my mom to tell her every. detail of my day at Wimbledon. She was thrilled. Yesterday was one of the best days of my life. I don't even know where to begin. I took a ton of pictures and jotted things down on my notes app so I could share in my journal. Let's start with my outfit. Fit check. I wore a green linen dress by Bowden and comfy white sneakers with a green trim by Viva. I don't know how to say it. And then I also brought a tote bag with an empty water bottle because you can refill it once you get inside sunscreen and a hat. very important.
9.30 a.m.
We left early to grab some breakfast to go, or as they say here, to take away.
And then we took the train from Marble Arch to Wimbledon.
Thank you to the folks we met at a coffee shop who told us to get off at Southfield Station.
If you guys ever go and take the tube, get off there.
Then you walk to the entrance gates of Wimbledon and it's not a bad walk, about 15 minutes.
The whole walk to the gates, I had a body buzz.
You could feel a joy in the crowd we walked with, a huge group of strangers all dressed
9.30 a.m. We left early to grab some breakfast to go, or as they say here, to take away. And then we took the train from Marble Arch to Wimbledon. Thank you to the folks we met at a coffee shop who told us to get off at Southfield Station. If you guys ever go and take the tube, get off there. Then you walk to the entrance gates of Wimbledon and it's not a bad walk, about 15 minutes. The whole walk to the gates, I had a body buzz. You could feel a joy in the crowd we walked with, a huge group of strangers all dressed
and what looked like their Sunday best, excited for the day ahead.
10.30 a.m. walking into the courts, we had four tickets, two to center court and two to court one.
Throughout the day, we would trade seats so we could see different matches.
The first match I saw was on center court. Walking into that stadium felt like a religious experience.
Our seats were across from the royal box, so I had a great view of Roger Federer and Billy Jean King, OMG.
The match was amazing. It was Jasmine Paulini and Alice.
Alexandra Iola, and they absolutely floored me. We had two very charming men from Italy sitting behind us,
and whenever Paulini hit a winner, they would chant, bravissimo, bravissimo. It's such good people
and what looked like their Sunday best, excited for the day ahead. 10.30 a.m. walking into the courts, we had four tickets, two to center court and two to court one. Throughout the day, we would trade seats so we could see different matches. The first match I saw was on center court. Walking into that stadium felt like a religious experience. Our seats were across from the royal box, so I had a great view of Roger Federer and Billy Jean King, OMG. The match was amazing. It was Jasmine Paulini and Alice. Alexandra Iola, and they absolutely floored me. We had two very charming men from Italy sitting behind us, and whenever Paulini hit a winner, they would chant, bravissimo, bravissimo. It's such good people
watching at Wimbledon, too. I met a woman named Jude, who had a hat covered in tennis balls,
but somehow it was also fashionable. I asked her where she got it, and she told me she made it.
She said, all you need is a glue gun. I got very excited. I have a glue gun, and I want to make one.
Oh, dear. And she let me.
me take a picture, lady, of her hat, and I really want to try to make it.
Will I be the crazy lady wearing a hat with tennis balls?
Yeah, maybe.
Okay.
watching at Wimbledon, too. I met a woman named Jude, who had a hat covered in tennis balls, but somehow it was also fashionable. I asked her where she got it, and she told me she made it. She said, all you need is a glue gun. I got very excited. I have a glue gun, and I want to make one. Oh, dear. And she let me. me take a picture, lady, of her hat, and I really want to try to make it. Will I be the crazy lady wearing a hat with tennis balls? Yeah, maybe. Okay.
Back to my journal.
Throughout the day, there were so many fantastic matches, I felt humbled to be there
and spent the day in awe.
There was a moment I won't forget.
It was in the Arthur Ferry and Grigor Dimitrov match.
Ferry won the wild card slot to play.
This means he didn't have a high enough ranking to normally get a chance to compete.
He wouldn't have even been there.
Back to my journal. Throughout the day, there were so many fantastic matches, I felt humbled to be there and spent the day in awe. There was a moment I won't forget. It was in the Arthur Ferry and Grigor Dimitrov match. Ferry won the wild card slot to play. This means he didn't have a high enough ranking to normally get a chance to compete. He wouldn't have even been there.
But he got the wild card.
and Dimitrov has been on the professional tennis circuit around 18 years.
The energy in that stadium was absolutely electric.
They played amazing tennis and went five sets that led then to an insane tiebreaker.
Ferry is from the Wimbledon area, and at one point when the stadium was very quiet,
a fan yelled,
Go on Ferry!
And the place went nuts.
But he got the wild card. and Dimitrov has been on the professional tennis circuit around 18 years. The energy in that stadium was absolutely electric. They played amazing tennis and went five sets that led then to an insane tiebreaker. Ferry is from the Wimbledon area, and at one point when the stadium was very quiet, a fan yelled, Go on Ferry! And the place went nuts.
This match could have easily gone either way.
but in the end, fairy won, and the place went berserk.
Here's this local kid with a wildcard, now going to the quarterfinals at Wimbledon.
You felt the weight of that moment, wash over him, and he dropped to the ground.
I had to wipe away some tears, and I wasn't the only one.
I looked around that Pax Stadium, and people were crying, hugging, and cheering.
It made me think of our discussion with Mike Scher about fandom.
This one singular moment brought a crowd of strangers together in pure joy and the food and drink of it all.
This match could have easily gone either way. but in the end, fairy won, and the place went berserk. Here's this local kid with a wildcard, now going to the quarterfinals at Wimbledon. You felt the weight of that moment, wash over him, and he dropped to the ground. I had to wipe away some tears, and I wasn't the only one. I looked around that Pax Stadium, and people were crying, hugging, and cheering. It made me think of our discussion with Mike Scher about fandom. This one singular moment brought a crowd of strangers together in pure joy and the food and drink of it all.
Yes, I needed to know if you had strawberries and pimms.
Yes, I had strawberries and cream and a PIMS.
And I got to go into the Wimbledon broadcast building.
I hopped on the Access All England show, which is a behind the scenes live stream on the Wimbledon app with my dear friend Nick McCarville and his co-host and former professional tennis player, Jill Crabus.
Shout out to everyone in the broadcast building.
They let me keep my giant bag of merch there all day so I didn't have to carry it around.
I think I bought everything they make in the Wimbledo shop because, you know, I love the merch,
exclamation point.
Yes, I needed to know if you had strawberries and pimms. Yes, I had strawberries and cream and a PIMS. And I got to go into the Wimbledon broadcast building. I hopped on the Access All England show, which is a behind the scenes live stream on the Wimbledon app with my dear friend Nick McCarville and his co-host and former professional tennis player, Jill Crabus. Shout out to everyone in the broadcast building. They let me keep my giant bag of merch there all day so I didn't have to carry it around. I think I bought everything they make in the Wimbledo shop because, you know, I love the merch, exclamation point.
And I have to share a lovely text I got that night from Beth in the broadcast building.
She said, we're here super late, so let me know whenever you're looking to grab your bits and bobs.
Do you want me to bring you guys some snacks or anything?
crisps are chocolate for the journey back.
We were starving.
All the food vendors had closed by that time.
So, Beth, thank you for the snacks.
We ate it on the way home.
And I have to share a lovely text I got that night from Beth in the broadcast building. She said, we're here super late, so let me know whenever you're looking to grab your bits and bobs. Do you want me to bring you guys some snacks or anything? crisps are chocolate for the journey back. We were starving. All the food vendors had closed by that time. So, Beth, thank you for the snacks. We ate it on the way home.
I have a video from the end of the day of us,
and we literally closed the place down.
We were there over 12 hours.
I didn't want to leave,
and I hope someday I get to go back.
All righty.
I've had my Queen Elizabeth Tea,
and now it's time for my very last day here.
I have a video from the end of the day of us, and we literally closed the place down. We were there over 12 hours. I didn't want to leave, and I hope someday I get to go back. All righty. I've had my Queen Elizabeth Tea, and now it's time for my very last day here.
We're going to Notting Hill and Richmond.
And then I have my last day.
Okay, last day in London, July 8th.
Hi from the London Heathrow Airport.
Today I go back home.
I miss my family and I'm ready for my bed.
But oh my goodness, do I love London?
Yesterday we went to Notting Hill.
We're going to Notting Hill and Richmond. And then I have my last day. Okay, last day in London, July 8th. Hi from the London Heathrow Airport. Today I go back home. I miss my family and I'm ready for my bed. But oh my goodness, do I love London? Yesterday we went to Notting Hill.
It's as charming as I could have imagined.
I loved all the buildings painted different colors and all the different shops.
Here's something to know about me.
Again, my journal who doesn't know me, I guess.
Never met you.
Yeah.
Here's something to know about me.
I love maps.
It's as charming as I could have imagined. I loved all the buildings painted different colors and all the different shops. Here's something to know about me. Again, my journal who doesn't know me, I guess. Never met you. Yeah. Here's something to know about me. I love maps.
I'm kind of obsessed with maps.
I have two different maps hanging as art in my house.
And for my folks who also like maps,
there is a fantastic vintage map store in Notting Hill.
The Portobello print and map shop.
Listen to what all they have.
Old maps, engravings, plus decorative flower, animal, and maritime prints.
Um, yes, please.
I'm kind of obsessed with maps. I have two different maps hanging as art in my house. And for my folks who also like maps, there is a fantastic vintage map store in Notting Hill. The Portobello print and map shop. Listen to what all they have. Old maps, engravings, plus decorative flower, animal, and maritime prints. Um, yes, please.
I really wanted this big map,
but I knew I couldn't fit at my suitcase.
So instead, I got this amazing antique engraving dated 1683.
It's of the port in Cartagena with all the old-timey boats pulling in.
It's so cool, I can't wait to show it to Josh.
After lunch, we went to Richmond.
My friend Rebecca lived there for a bit, and she showed me all of her stomping grounds.
What an absolutely wonderful town.
I really wanted this big map, but I knew I couldn't fit at my suitcase. So instead, I got this amazing antique engraving dated 1683. It's of the port in Cartagena with all the old-timey boats pulling in. It's so cool, I can't wait to show it to Josh. After lunch, we went to Richmond. My friend Rebecca lived there for a bit, and she showed me all of her stomping grounds. What an absolutely wonderful town.
We went to the open bookstore, and I met Madeline, who works there.
I was looking at books about Anne Boleyn,
and she took me into a smaller back room and went through a stack of books with me.
I settled on the House of Berlin by Tracy Borman.
I can't wait to dive into it.
Before we left the bookstore, Madeline gave us a rundown on every prime minister she thought was absolute rubbish.
Her word.
I literally said to her, I was like, well, it's nice meeting you.
We went to the open bookstore, and I met Madeline, who works there. I was looking at books about Anne Boleyn, and she took me into a smaller back room and went through a stack of books with me. I settled on the House of Berlin by Tracy Borman. I can't wait to dive into it. Before we left the bookstore, Madeline gave us a rundown on every prime minister she thought was absolute rubbish. Her word. I literally said to her, I was like, well, it's nice meeting you.
I'm going to go and she goes, not yet.
I have a little snark for you to take home.
She continued.
Next, we went to a pub called the White Cross.
It's famous for being the pub that floods.
It sits right on the Tim's River.
And as the tide rises later in the day, the beer garden and patio at the entrance of the pub flood.
But no worries.
I'm going to go and she goes, not yet. I have a little snark for you to take home. She continued. Next, we went to a pub called the White Cross. It's famous for being the pub that floods. It sits right on the Tim's River. And as the tide rises later in the day, the beer garden and patio at the entrance of the pub flood. But no worries.
They keep serving drinks and food even as it floods, and they have a sign hanging outside that says,
Can't get in because of high tide?
Call us to borrow some wellies.
Oh.
And then they have their phone number.
And they'll bring you a pair of wellies.
That's nice.
I know.
They keep serving drinks and food even as it floods, and they have a sign hanging outside that says, Can't get in because of high tide? Call us to borrow some wellies. Oh. And then they have their phone number. And they'll bring you a pair of wellies. That's nice. I know.
I was bummed because we couldn't stay for high tide.
We had to get back to Marble Arch to pack for our early flight home.
But we did have a glass of wine and watch World Cup, and I definitely want to go back there.
I have two last things to share.
One, I'm going to miss the announcement on the two.
see it, say it, sorted.
Yeah, my family still says that.
Because they say it over and over.
I was bummed because we couldn't stay for high tide. We had to get back to Marble Arch to pack for our early flight home. But we did have a glass of wine and watch World Cup, and I definitely want to go back there. I have two last things to share. One, I'm going to miss the announcement on the two. see it, say it, sorted. Yeah, my family still says that. Because they say it over and over.
Say it, sorted.
Love it.
Mind the gap, please.
Mind the gap.
And before I sign off here and get on my plane,
I wanted to jot down pubs and grape food I've had since I've been here.
In North London, in the Highgate area,
the bull and last, I got the ricotta stuffed corgut flour,
Say it, sorted. Love it. Mind the gap, please. Mind the gap. And before I sign off here and get on my plane, I wanted to jot down pubs and grape food I've had since I've been here. In North London, in the Highgate area, the bull and last, I got the ricotta stuffed corgut flour,
Parmesan and honey.
Delicious.
The red line and sun.
I got the chicken schnitzel, jalapeno, salsa, and Caesar salad.
The flask, we went for a Sunday roast.
So good.
I got the roasted pork belly with roasted potatoes,
maple carrots, squash, mash, cauliflower cheese, and seasonal greens,
Parmesan and honey. Delicious. The red line and sun. I got the chicken schnitzel, jalapeno, salsa, and Caesar salad. The flask, we went for a Sunday roast. So good. I got the roasted pork belly with roasted potatoes, maple carrots, squash, mash, cauliflower cheese, and seasonal greens,
Yorkshire pudding, and gravy.
Uli and Marleybone, which was a mix of Chinese Thai,
Malay, and Singaporean cuisine.
Amazing.
The Shed and Notting Hill, which is farm-to-table type of restaurant,
great food from their farms in Sussex.
And finally, on our last night, near our flat by Marble Arch, we went to Zanya, which is a restaurant that features Pakistani and North Indian cuisine.
Again, delicious.
Yorkshire pudding, and gravy. Uli and Marleybone, which was a mix of Chinese Thai, Malay, and Singaporean cuisine. Amazing. The Shed and Notting Hill, which is farm-to-table type of restaurant, great food from their farms in Sussex. And finally, on our last night, near our flat by Marble Arch, we went to Zanya, which is a restaurant that features Pakistani and North Indian cuisine. Again, delicious.
I think I gained six pounds since I've been here.
I feel so bloated.
Okay, bye for now.
I'm so tired and I can't wait to sleep on the plane.
Honestly, when we got back, that's the end of my journal.
I don't think I ate for like the first day.
I was like, no, I'm good.
I'm good.
我想我来这里后胖了六磅。我觉得肚子胀得厉害。好了，先这样。我太累了，迫不及待想在飞机上睡一觉。说实话，当我们回去的时候，我的日记就到此结束了。我觉得我大概第一天什么都没吃。我说，不，我挺好的。我挺好的。
I was texting with my mom and sisters, and I said, I don't think I need to eat a potato for like a month.
I ate so many potatoes.
I remember being in London and they love peas on the side.
Like in America where it's like green beans or broccoli, over there it's peas.
So many peas.
So many peas, but so many potatoes.
And potatoes, peas and potatoes.
Peas and potatoes.
我和我妈妈还有姐姐们发短信，我说，我大概有一个月不想吃土豆了。我吃了太多土豆。我记得在伦敦的时候，他们配菜喜欢吃豌豆。就像在美国是四季豆或西兰花一样，那边是豌豆。好多的豌豆。好多的豌豆，还有好多的土豆。还有土豆，豌豆和土豆。豌豆和土豆。
but that Sunday roast was like all those things come when you order.
Yeah.
All those things.
And it was so good.
Well, I loved that.
Yeah, that was great.
My favorite part continues to be the level of detail before the trip has even started.
Yes.
但那个周日烤肉大餐就像你点餐时所有这些东西都会端上来。是的。所有这些东西。而且太好吃了。嗯，我很喜欢那个。是的，那太棒了。我最喜欢的依然是在旅行甚至还没开始时的细节程度。是的。
The way to the airport.
Yes.
It's the best.
I mean, you get in a car like an old Toyota that says Moki Mobile and you can't share that?
Come on.
I hear you.
But yeah, it was a truly amazing trip.
Those are the details that I think most people don't put in their journals.
去机场的路上。是的。这太棒了。我是说，你坐上一辆像旧丰田一样的车，上面写着“莫基移动”，你不能分享这个吗？拜托。我懂你的意思。但是是的，这是一次真正美妙的旅行。这些细节我认为大多数人都不会记在日记里。
I would say between the two of you, you paint a full picture of a moment.
This is why we need to travel somewhere together.
Yes.
And each tell the story.
But I want it to be somewhere neither of us have ever been.
Yeah.
So it's new because it's the newness, right?
Yes.
我可以说你们俩结合起来，就能生动地描绘出一个时刻。这就是为什么我们需要一起去某个地方旅行。是的。然后各自讲述这个故事。但我希望是一个我们俩从来都没去过的地方。是的。所以它是崭新的，因为那种新鲜感，对吧？是的。
So I don't know where that is, but we need to do it.
We'll figure it out.
That's going to be our next travel journals episode.
Okay.
But Sam, you went to Germany.
We'd love to hear about it.
I did.
所以我不知道那在哪里，但我们需要去。我们会想办法的。我们会想办法的。这将是我们下一期旅行日记节目。好的。但是萨姆，你去了德国。我们很想听听。我去了。
Okay, so full listener disclosure, we were originally going to record a couple weeks ago.
So I intended to send this in for you guys to listen to while I wasn't here.
That's right.
You were going to send us an audio file, right?
From Germany.
Mine is an audio recording from my hotel room in Munich.
So I flew to Canada.
Then my girlfriend, Steph and her family, we flew from Canada to Munich,
好吧，给听众朋友们交代一下，我们本来打算几周前录音的。所以我原本打算把这个发给你们，让你们在我不在的时候听。没错。你本来要给我们发一个音频文件，对吧？来自德国。我的是一段来自我慕尼黑酒店房间的录音。所以我飞到了加拿大。然后我的女友斯黛普和她的家人，我们从加拿大飞往慕尼黑，
and then took a six-hour train up to Osnebrook for her cousin's wedding.
So that was two weeks and then we saw a bunch of stuff in eight Schnitzel twice a day.
It was great.
So without further ado, here we go.
All right.
What?
You get in music?
Oh, yeah.
然后坐了六个小时的火车去奥斯纳布鲁克参加她表妹的婚礼。所以那是两周，然后我们看了很多东西，一天吃两次炸肉排。太棒了。废话不多说，我们开始吧。好吧。什么？你在慕尼黑？哦，是的。
1222.
Greetings office ladies.
It's Sam and I'm in Canada, the land of Celine Dion and Poutine.
Myself and Stephanie are on our way through her parents' house to take a van together to the airport.
I'm aware this is exactly how Home Alone starts, so I'll be counting everyone before we get in the van.
Steph's parents really highlight the difference in our travel.
Or more accurately, they highlight the poor box car hobo way I've traveled.
For instance, her dad was insistent I get travel insurance.
1222。问候各位办公室女士。我是萨姆，我在加拿大，席琳·迪翁和肉汁奶酪薯条的故乡。我和斯黛普正在去她父母家的路上，打算一起坐面包车去机场。我知道这和《小鬼当家》的开场一模一样，所以在上车前我会数一数所有人。斯黛普的父母真的很突显我们旅行方式的不同。或者更准确地说，他们突显了我那种穷酸流浪汉式的糟糕旅行方式。比如，她爸爸坚决要我买旅游保险。
What the f*** is travel insurance?
Steph asked me what I would do if I got hurt in another country.
I thought about it and realized as a proud American, my plan was if I ever got hurt in another country,
I would simply die there.
They would put my hat on a poorly made cross on the spot where they buried me like an Oregon Trail.
3 p.m.
We arrived at the airport.
Steph's pre-flight anxiety is again highlighting my complete lack of interior flight sense.
什么鬼是旅游保险？斯黛普问我如果在另一个国家受伤了会怎么办。我想了想，意识到作为一个骄傲的美国人，我的计划是如果我在另一个国家受伤，我就会直接死在那里。他们会把我的帽子挂在我被埋葬的地方附近一个粗制滥造的十字架上，就像《俄勒冈小道》里那样。下午3点。我们到达了机场。斯黛普的行前焦虑再次突显了我完全缺乏内心的飞行感知。
She travels much how I imagine Jenna would fly, with her travel documentation in an alphabetical binder by her side.
Whereas I travel how I imagine Angela travels.
My passport loose in my backpack stickily covered in Sour Patch Kid Sugar.
7 a.m. the next morning.
We have arrived in Munich.
Our flight was eight hours so we got a full meal and a breakfast.
Steph and her mom didn't want any yogurt, so I got three.
full yogurt. I know that
她旅行的方式很像我想象中珍娜坐飞机的方式，她的身边带着按字母顺序排列的旅行文件活页夹。而我旅行的方式则很像我想象中安吉拉旅行的方式。我的护照散落在双肩背包里，上面黏糊糊地沾满了酸甜软糖的糖分。第二天早上7点。我们已经到达慕尼黑。我们的飞行时间是八个小时，所以我们吃了一顿正餐和一顿早餐。斯黛普和她妈妈不要酸奶，所以我拿了三个。满杯的酸奶。我知道那个
sentence will be exciting for both Jenna and
Angela. 7.47am.
Slight airport train to airport baggage claim.
I am delirious with airplane sleep and nothing coming out of
my mouth makes sense to me. Nothing I need
to worry about. Not my monkey, not my circus.
That's my motto.
Nichtmein afe. Nicktemein circus.
句子对珍娜和安吉拉来说都会很兴奋。早上7点47分。转机去机场行李提取处。我因为在飞机上睡觉而神志不清，我嘴里说出来的任何话对我来说都没有意义。我不需要担心的事情。不是我的猴子，不是我的马戏团。那是我的座右铭。这不是我的猴子。这不是我的马戏团。
10 a.m. We are attempting to take the train from Munich Airport to
Steph's uncle's house. We've already gotten off on an
incorrect stop and then a bus no one told us to take.
We are back in the train. We got off.
1220 a.m. I've now been traveling for 24 hours. My passport has merged with my hands and I am only able to say Guten Tag and Ishizes Sam, but we are at the hotel, which has no AC. So with Maen or Kirchiff and I in my cap, I've just settled in for a 90 degree Fahrenheit, 35 degrees Celsius nap.
Thanks to global warming, because 60 years ago, a bunch of baby boomers threw a bunch of styrofoam in the forest.
And now I'll never be able to afford a house and the world is on fire. And I eat a credit cards.
worth of microplastic each week.
上午10点。我们正试图坐火车从慕尼黑机场去斯黛普叔叔家。我们已经在错误的车站下过一次车，然后又坐了一辆没人告诉我们要坐的公交车。我们回到了火车上。我们下车了。凌晨12点20分。我旅行已经24小时了。我的护照已经和我的手长成一体了，我只会说“你好”和“我叫萨姆”，但我们到了酒店，这里没有空调。所以穿着我的衬衫，我刚刚安顿下来准备来个华氏90度（摄氏35度）的午睡。多亏了全球变暖，因为60年前，一堆婴儿潮一代在森林里扔了一堆聚苯乙烯泡沫塑料。现在我再也买不起房子了，世界正在燃烧。而且我每周都要吃掉价值一张信用卡的微塑料。
Gutenabbin.
So that was sent out of my mind.
Do you definitely get best production value?
That was so cool.
From my hotel room.
No way.
That was so cool.
What a crazy long travel day.
晚上好。所以那是传达我的心声。你绝对能得到最佳制作价值吗？太酷了。从我的酒店房间。不会吧。太酷了。多么疯狂漫长的旅行日。还有一件事。
And here's the thing.
The trip itself, despite the delirium of travel, was gorgeous.
I'd never been to Germany before.
Munich was awesome.
We took a bullet train, which went like 250 miles an hour up to Osnabrook.
Osnabrook was built in 780 AD.
Like that's 1,200 years ago.
America's like 250 years old.
而且关键是。尽管旅行让人神志不清，但这次旅行本身非常美妙。我以前从没去过德国。慕尼黑棒极了。我们坐了子弹头列车，以每小时250英里的速度开往奥斯纳布鲁克。奥斯纳布鲁克建于公元780年。就像那是1200年前的事。美国大概才250年历史。
Oh, I know.
So everything there is so old and still operational.
Like it was built well.
And like there's a church there that was around since I think 800.
Just casually you can just pop your head and it was crazy.
So cool.
Yeah.
Well, everyone, we hope you enjoyed this episode about all of our summer travels.
哦，我知道。所以那里的每一样东西都那么古老，而且还在运行。就像它质量很好一样。而且那里有一座教堂，我想从800年左右就在那儿了。你可以随随便便探个头进去，这太疯狂了。太酷了。是的。好吧，各位，我们希望你们喜欢这期关于我们所有夏日旅行的节目。
If you have a suggestion for where you think.
and I should go on our trip that we will then journal about. Will you please write us?
We have a new folder at officeladys.com for general mail. So tell us in the general mailbox
where you think Angela and I should go in this world for our duo travel journal. Okay.
We can't wait to hear. I really am excited. And thank you guys for listening. We hope you enjoyed our
summer travels and we'll see you next time. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office
Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
如果你对我和你应该去哪里进行我们将要写日记的旅行有什么建议。你能给我们写信吗？我们在 officeladys.com 上为一般邮件开设了一个新文件夹。所以请在一般信箱里告诉我们，你认为安吉拉和我应该去世界的哪个地方进行我们的双人旅行日记。好的。我们迫不及待地想听到。我真的很兴奋。谢谢你们的收听。我们希望你们喜欢我们的夏日旅行，我们下次再见。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔，我们的音频工程师是萨姆·派弗。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
Odyssey 的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。